chers collègues nous avons le plaisir et
le privilège je dirais c'est le
privilège faut faut pas dire ça le
privilège monsieur Baladur cétait fait
cétait fait charrier quand il était
rentré à à l'Assemblée nationale comme
premier j'ai le privilège je parler le
privilège j'ai le privilège de
d'accueillir par parmi nous ce matin
monsieur Gérard Harot que nous
connaissons tous mais que avec lequel
nous avons nous allons avoir un grand
bonheur de discussion monsieur Harot
comme vous le savez est ambassadeur de
de France et il a euh dans dans sa
corbeille
un un un héritage extraordinaire
puisqu'il a été particulièrement
précieux dans les affaires qui nous
occupent aujourd'hui puisqu'il a été
successivement euh ambassadeur euh euh
en Israël ambassadeur euh à l'ONU et
ambassadeur aux États-Unis donc ça fait
quand même quelque chose de
de très complet pour saisir cet
inextricable dossier par tous les bouts
à la fois alors Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
je vous souhaite évidemment la la
bienvenue
euh vous avez été en poste à Tel Aviv
comme premier secrétaire d'abord en de
82 à 84 puis comme ambassadeur de 2003 à
2006 donc vous avez vu se construire euh
cette nouvelle cette nouvelle
organisation politique de l'État
d'Israël et c'est quelque chose de très
précieux vous avez suivi les questions
du Moyen-Orient au centre au Cap vous
avez de 84 à 87 donc tout ça est
formidable euh et
[Musique]
vous alors parlons d'abord d'Israël un
mot sur
Israël je crois que l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles nous sommes
particulièrement heureux de vous
entendre c'est précisément la
compréhension de la dynamique interne à
à l'État
hébreu qu'est-ce qui s'est passé comment
analysez-vous les modifications qui nous
semblent structurelles apporté sous le
l'autorité notamment du Premier ministre
d'Israël actuel par rapport à des
positionsquell nous n'étions pas
fondamentalement toujours d'accord mais
qui était quand même très sensiblement
différente et dont
la l'image emblématique a été été
fournie par ITAC Rabine mais donc c'est
comment en est-on arrivé là en Israël
comment en est-on arrivé à ce type
d'appréhens à cette modification du
rapport d'Israël à son entourage nous
sommes convaincus que le le 7 octobre
n'est pas né de rien il est né il est la
conséquence de beaucoup de choses mais
notamment des évolutions intérieures
de l'État israélien et ça c'est quelque
chose de très précieux pour nous et vous
avez certainement compte tenu du de ce
que je viens
d'évoquer des choses tout à fait un
témoignage tout à fait particulier à
nous donner vous avez été ensuite
ambassadeur aux Nations Unies
représentant oui ça sonne toujours au
mauvais moment cere cl c'est c'est c'est
absolument classique ne vous inquiétez
pas ça m'arrive tout le temps et là
encore quand on voit la façon dont
s'organise ou se désorganise je ne sais
pas si j'ai toujours présente à l'esprit
la formule du général de GA qui
l'Organisation des Nations unies ou
plutôt l'organisation des Nations
désunies ou mieux encore la
désorganisation des nations des Unies je
ne sais pas où on en est sur ces trois
ces trois stades mais en tout cas le le
le l'éclairage que vous avez euh sur le
fonctionnement du du Conseil de sécurité
sur le fonctionnement de la l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies nous nous
nous sera également extrêmement précieux
parce que la communauté internationale
même si elle n'est pas une communauté
internationale elle est plus
internationale que communautaire si
j'ose dire elle se matérialise elle se
concrétise dans les travaux de New York
et et et là c'est certainement vous êtes
particulièrement qualifié pour nous
éclairer enfin vous avez été ambassadeur
aux États-Unis euh et là encore
l'évolution américaine est quelque chose
de très difficile à saisir nous sommes
évidemment très
satisfait de du cours que Monsieur Biden
a donné à sa politique depuis qu'il a
été élu par rapport à celle du président
Trump ce qui ne veut pas dire que nous
soyons satisfaits de toutes les
décisions prises par l'administration
américaine notamment en matière
économique et social nous voyons bien à
quel point la concurrence est vive avec
l'Union européenne et à quel point
l'Union européenne paraît en situation
difficile pour pour
équilibrer pour faire face à cette
nouvelle concurrence qui est représentée
par le plan américain mais sur le plan
international nous nous sommes quand
même très sensibles à ce qu'a fait à ce
que fait monsieur Biden pour apporter de
la modération dans ce conflit mais en
même temps nous voyons bien que la
France a du mal
à à se distinguer très clairement et de
façon
cohérente et continue à se distinguer de
ce qu'est la la politique américaine
aujourd'hui donc là derrière ce cette
responsabilité que vous avez eu il y a
tout le regard que vous pouvez porter à
la fois sur la politique américaine et
par contraste sur la politique
européenne ou si je j'ose dire sur
l'absence de politique européenne parce
que voyez-vous cher amis vous me
connaissez je suis un Européen convaincu
mais j'ai l'habitude de dire que je suis
je ne suis pas pour autant un Européen
heureux et et donc je mesure chaque jour
les insuffisances de notre politique
alors voilà il y a ce que nous attendons
de de vous c'est d'une part l'éclairage
sur ce qui s'est produit sur la
représentation que les Israéliens le
gouvernement et l'opinion publique
peuvent se faire de leur avenir ce que
nous ce que nous attendons de vous euh
sur l'examen précis de la situation moi
ce qui en tout cas ce que j'attends moi
ce qui me me choque beaucoup
actuellement c'est
l'incompréhension de la position
structurelle de l'État israëlien je veux
dire on on discute de la trêve on
discute du cesser le feu on discute de
choses mais ce qui en surplombe cette
discussion c'est l'extrême difficulté
que nous avons à percevoir le concept
géostratégique euh et donc géopolitique
qui est celui de du gouvernement
israélien quand il mène la politique la
politique c'est la continuation euh la
guerre c'est la continuation de la
politique par d'autres moyens nous
voyons bien la mobilisation de forces
militaires importantes nous voyons bien
les dommages qui sont causés ici et là
et surtout enfin terrible dans la bande
de Gaza mais nous avons énormément de
mal si tenter qu'elle existe à percevoir
quelle est la vision finale que l'État
israélien donne à à ce conflit comment
veut-il organiser structurellement ses
relations avec son environnement nous
nous avons toujours été porteurs nous
autres Européens d'une vision
sommairement résumé dans deux États mais
enfin au-delà ça nous avons toujours été
porteurs d'une vision disant qu'il
fallait une une relation d'apaisement
une relation de compréhension réciproque
une relation dans lequelle les
aspirations légitimes du peuple
palestinien soi pris en compte si on
voulait qu'Israël vive durablement en
sécurité en
sérénité là nous sommes évidemment
totalement à l'opposé de tout cela et et
nous avons énormément de mal à nous
définir par rapport à cela alors c'est
tout cela alors j'ai parlé de votre
carrière diplomatique trop rapidement
j'aurais pu évoquer votre carrière
littéraire si je puis dire vous depuis
que vous avez quitté vos fonctions
d'ambassadeur vous êtes d'une d'une
fécondité éditoriale absolument
extraordinaire vous avez lu vous avez
publié quantité de livres tous remarqua
le livre sur Kissinger et celui je dois
dire auquel j'ai été le plus sensible
parce
que je pense que j'appartiens à cette
vieille génération qui au bout du compte
a été formée par la mémoire de nos
parents sur ce qu'ils ont vécu entre
1914 et 1945 et nous étions seuls qui
est un livre que je vous recommande
chers collègues qui était vraiment une
analyse et je crois que le titre
d'ailleurs dit tout le titre dit bien
que le problème fondamental c'était la
solitude française donc tout cela vous
donne évidemment une compétence générale
pour nous parler des choses mais j'ai
commencé par le particulier j'ai
commencé par vos trois postes et j'ai
commencé par ces interrogations c'est
cuide de ce que veut Israël que veut
quid de ce que veulent les États-Unis de
ce qu'ils peuvent faire de ce qu'il
risqu de ne plus faire si Monsieur Trump
est élu dans dans un an et cuide de
cette malheureuse Europe qui balbue des
idées justes mais est incapable de les
transformer en acte fort voilà le le
alors le notre système c'est vous faites
une introduction de de entre 10 minutes
et 20 minutes et ensuite chaque groupe
vous interroge 2 minutes et dem et vous
répondez dans le même lapse de temps
étant entendu que je suis totalement
impuissant à à l'idée de vous empêcher
de dépasser les 2 minutes et demi je
suis dans une position d'infériorité
c'est pourquoi dès le départ j'implore
votre votre
autorégulation voilà Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur cher Gérard har vous avez
la parole merci mer monsieur le
Président Mesdames mesdames Messieurs
les les parlementaires et Mesdames
Messieurs c'est c'est évidemment un
honneur d'être d'être devant vous ce
matin alors il se trouve que j'ai sans
doute une fécondité éditoriale et je
suis en train de de d'écrire un livre
sur Israël figurez-vous qu'il y a 6 mois
j'avais cette donné cette idée à mon
éditeur qui m'avait dit non un livre sur
Israël ça ne se vend pas et je ne sais
pas pourquoi l'éditeur m'a rappelé il y
a 2 semaines pour me dire bah finalement
vous pouvez vous pouvez y aller
euh donc je vais essayer d'être bref sur
Israël lui-même
euh vous savez lorsque Israël a fait la
conquête de la sisjouranie en en juin
1967 bengouron avait dit si nous ne
partons pas tout de suite nous ne
partirons jamais et et le problème
central que de la justice Jordanie c'est
que c'est la terre de la
Bible et donc vous avez là un double
blocage d'abord le blocage sécuritaire
parce que faire un État palestinien en
Cisjordanie c'est 14 ce serait avoir un
État palestinien à 14 km de tavive à 5
km du du de l'aéroport de bengouron donc
une roquette et le pays et le pays
sarrête et il faut bien se dire que les
Israéliens du fait de l'histoire à la
fois tragique du peuple juif et
l'histoire d'Israël ne veulent pas la
paix ils veulent la
sécurité c'est-à-dire que d'une certaine
manière Israël est en Guer depuis 1948
et donc Israël d'une certaine manière a
l'habitude si j'ose dire de vivre dans
ces conditions mais pour eux la
l'objectif central c'est la sécurité
deuxièmement c'est une sécurité qui ne
peut-être assurée que par eux du fait de
l'histoire les Israéliens ne font
confiance à personne pour leur sécurité
et certainement pas aux États-Unis par
exemple et donc toute idée d'une force
internationale d'une force arabe d'une
forces des nations- Unies n'a pas la
moindre chance d'être accepté par un
pays qui d'une certaine manière est je
dirais c un peu paranoïque paranoïque
parce que l'histoire lui a appris qu'il
y avait des raisons de de l'être donc
vous avez un premier obstacle pour cette
sis Jordanie c'est donc la question de
la sécurité et comme vous pouvez vous
imaginer après ce qui s'est passé à Gaza
ce qui s'est passé le 7 octobre euh vous
pouvez bien imaginer que ça ne pousse
pas les Israéliens à faire des
concessions supplémentaires une sis
Jordanie qui serait évidemment qui est
beaucoup plus proche du cœur même de
l'état de de l'État hébreu la deuxième
raison je l'ai dit aussi c'est le
problème religieux c'est que la la
s-jordanie c'est la terre de la Bible et
euh c'est difficile de de parler de ces
de ces sujets mais c'est vrai que l'on a
assisté d'une certaine manière à la
rencontre euh un peu mortifère de la
religion et du
nationalisme vous avez une toute une
droite nationale religieuse qui vous
savez lorsqu'on était lorsque les les
Juifs étaient dans le chtettel en
Pologne ou ailleurs il rêvaent il priait
de vous savez il priait au rythme au
rythme agricole de la Palestine même
s'ils étaient en palestin même s'ils
étaient en Pologne mais d'une certaine
manière la terre de la Bible devenait
une réalité é un peu spirituelle là la
terre de la Bible elle s'incarne elle
s'incarne dans des caillaces elle
s'incarne dans des lieux parce que
naturellement tout le monde a pris sa
Bible et a identifié tel ou tel auteur
en sis Jordanie à tel ou tel épisode à
tel ou tel épisode de la Bible et donc
vous avez maintenant des milliers de de
de colons israéliens qui se sont
installé en Cisjordanie et qui vous
disent cette terre m'a été donnée par
Dieu il est évidemment hors de question
que j'y que j'y renonce et et donc et on
le voit en ce moment d'ailleurs
profitant de la tragédie de Gaza on voit
bien les colons israéliens qui se
livrent à des violences au dépend des
Palestiniens qui il faut bien dire
reviennent à faire un peu un nettoyage
ethnique au détail pas on en profite
pour se débarrasser d'un village qui est
gênant d'une d'une d'une petite d'une
agglomération voire voire voire voire
d'une voire d'une famille et donc c'est
cette je crois que c'est là le cœur du
du conflit c'est je ne je ne connais pas
de gouvernement israélien même
concevable aujourd'hui qui serait
capable de rapatrier de rapatrier les
colons vous avez en gros en s-jordanie
un demiillion ou un demiillion c'est-àd
au-delà de la ligne verte vous savez la
ligne d'armistice de 1949 1967 vous avez
maintenant à peu près un demiillion
d'Israéliens sur ce demi-illion on peut
se dire que 350 ou 400 sont dans des
blocs proches de Jérusalem et que donc
en faisant des rectifications de
frontières assez minimes on parviendrait
à les intégrer dans Israël mais il reste
à peu près une centaine de milliers de
colons qui sont armés qui sont
déterminés et qui sont ne sont pas des
colons économiques vous savez j'avais un
chauffeur à l'ambassade qui habitait
dans une dans une de de ces colonies et
qui me disait bah tout simplement il
avait eu des il avait eu des des prê à
tau bas parce que les état favorise la
colon la colonisation et que l'air y
était bon et c'était tout ça était situé
à 30 km de l'ambassade et donc il y a en
effet des colons économiques cela il
rentrerait sans de assez aisément en
Israël moyennant indemnisation mais il y
a aussi ces colons ces colons
idéologiques et vous savez lorsque de
temps de temps en temps enfin c'est
vraiment de temps en temps très rarement
certaines de ces implantations sont
illégales même au regard du droit
israélien et donc de temps en temps
l'État se décide à en évacuer une par la
force et alors ça devient un mélodrame
national l'armée y va et tout ça pour 10
ou 15 excités sur une colline l'armée y
va et tout ceci de fait la première page
des journaux et on a l'impression que le
pays entier est plongé d'un seul coup
dans dans dans un mélodrame donc c'est
je je pour cette double raison je dirais
raison sécuritaire et raison idéologique
il est aujourd'hui il me semble
aujourd'hui très difficile d'imaginer la
création d'un État palestinien avec un
État palestinien qui soit viable et
contigu alors ça ne veut pas dire que
l'opinion publique israélienne soit
massivement euh dise massivement nous
voulons conserver la sis-jordanie mais
l'opinion publique israélienne d'une
certaine manière la grande majorité elle
est je dirais apatique apatique d'un
côté vous avez les euh vous avez les les
colons et ceux qui les soutiennent toute
l'extrême droite nationale religieuse
parce que si vous êtes ultraorthodoxe
c'est c'est différent mais la l'extrême
droite nationale religieuse veut
conserver à tout prix la sisjordanie est
prêt à mourir pour elle mais du côté de
l'opinion publique disons qu'il y a une
certaine indifférence à ce sujet pour
d'abord une raison pratique on n'a pas
le droit d'aller en Cisjordanie donc les
les Israéliens de hafa ou de Tel Aviv
ils ne connaissent pas la sisjordanie
ils n'y vont pas pour aller à
sisjordanie vous devez être logé
domicilier en en Cisjordanie et puis
deuxième raison parce que il n'y a pas
d'alternative au fond ils disent bah
voilà le statut quo pour les les
Israéliens jusqu'au 7 octobre en tout
cas le satatu était de loin la solution
la plus confortable alors pendant ce
temps les colons grignai peu à peu la
sisjordanie mais les Israéliens de
highfi de Tel Aviv se disaient que
finalement le la le statut quo a été
confortable et surtout qu'il n'y avait
pas d'alternative donc bon à part le
statut quo qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait faire
il n'y avait pas de
négociation et donc je dirais que tout
le monde se contentait relativement de
de ces de cette de cette situation voilà
un petit peu donc où on en était le le
le le le 7 octobre un statut quo qui
était très confortable finalement pour
Israël qui permettait notamment à Israël
de faire à peu près ce qu'il voulait
dans la en S Jordanie cette 6 Jordanie à
laquelle lesput à laquelle les
Israéliens sont tattaché et comme je
l'ai dit principalement pour deux
raisons la sécurité et deuxièmement la
la la la religion voilà un petit peu
cette introduction sur ce sujet j'espère
que je n'ai pas été trop long on
pourrait évidemment parler nuancé nuancé
il faut aussi citer quand même il faut
aussi parler de l'évolution politique de
l'État d'Israël où la gauche a disparu
la gauche a physiquement disparu au au
au aux élections et euh où donc le
spectre politique israélien s'est
déporté peu à peu d'ailleurs au fil des
années on a bien on a on a vu la la
disparition de la gauche progressive euh
s'est s'est déplacé vers la droite et
aujourd'hui on a quand même un Israël
euh très différent de l'Israël que je
connaissais certainement en 1982 quand
je suis arrivé pour la première fois
dans ces état dans cet état mais encore
en Israël différent de celui de 2003
avec un spectre politique qui
aujourd'hui nous amène au sein du
gouvernement israélien à des ministres
qui ne sont même pas d'extrême droite
qui sont d'ultra droite euh comme
smotrich ou benvir qui sont des
ministres qui dont le le programme est
proprement effrayant
euh voilà donc donc cette situation et
euh hier je déjeunais avec des amis
israéliens et euh c'est évident que nous
nous rêvons tous que après après cet
affrontement après cette tragédie euh
après cette confrontation on en revienne
à la négociation et eux me disaient mais
moins que jamais il me disaient étant
donné le traumatisme qu'a souffert qu'a
subi le peuple le le peuple le peuple
israélien il est vraiment très difficile
il est vraiment très difficile
d'imaginer que des Israéliens se
mettront autour de la table pour faire
des concessions parce que euh si l'on
voit une négociation qui s'ouvre cette
négociation étant donné la position de
force d'Israël ce sera une ce sera une
position qui nécessiterait des
concessions de la part d'Israël et
aujourd'hui il est je dirais quasiment
du du bon sens de se dire que ce n'est
pas particulièrement pas
particulièrement le moment où l'on peut
on peut
l'espérer alors je dis dans 5 ans dans
10 ans peut-être mais en tout cas voilà
un petit peu où l'on en est et tout ceci
me semble à la fois désespérant parce
que des êtres humains sont en train de
mourir hein on sont déjà morts ets sont
en train de mourir et un peu désespérés
parce que je ne vois pas comment on peut
sortir de la confrontation actuelle
comme on dit auokedor c'est par le haut
euh en général lorsqu'un diplomate vous
dit ça c'est qu'il n'a pas la moindre
idée comment il va s'en sortir donc
essayer de s'en sortir par le haut euh
je ne vois vraiment pas euh comment cela
pourrait être cela pourrait être le cas
dans le le le le le en même temps je
rappeler un certain nombre de choses
quand même c'est euh à l'évidence l'Iran
ne veut pas y aller à l'évidence l'Iran
ne veut pas y aller et si les Américains
ont deux pores-avion en en Méditerranée
orientale ce n'est pas contre Gaza mais
c'est évidemment pour dissuader l'Iran
l'Iran d'y aller et au sein du monde
arabe
euh tous les gouvernements auquels je
pense sont sont seraiit ravi si Israël
éradiquait le Hamas hein je vous
rappelle que tout pour tous les gouvern
arabe en particulier l'Égypte
naturellement les monarchies du golf le
Hamas et l'ennemi absolu et que donc je
dirais que les pays arabes s'il
n'avaient pas une opinion publique les
pays arabes regarderaient ailleurs vous
avez d'ailleurs vu une réunion de la
Ligue arabe la Ligue arabe s'est réunie
et n'a pas pris la moindre décision
contre Israël elle n'a même pas demandé
qu'on rappelle les ambassadeurs euh il y
a au niveau des des états il y a une
véritable je dirait rapprochement
collusion ou rapprochement entre Israël
et les pays arabes face au au Hamas mais
la question est évidemment que le Hamas
en revanche est extrêmement populaire
dans les opinions publiques ce sont des
états tous autoritaires euh mais ils
doivent néanmoins quand même faire un
minimum si je dire un minimum syndical
pour pour répondre à la colère ou au
pression de leur opinion publique donc
je pense que sauf si le conflit dur
vraiment je ne vois pas pour le moment
pour le moment de risque d'extension du
conflit au-delà au-delà d'Israël de ce
qui arrive aujourd'hui et qui est
suffisamment tragique entre Israël et
Gaza vous ne souhaitez pas en dire
davantage sur la situation à Gaza
notamment sur le je ne suis pas un
expert militaire hein donc je dois vous
avouer je ne veux pas comment encore pas
non je c'est votre prochain livre je ne
suis pas toutologue que comme c'est ce
que je dis souvent donc je militairement
je ne sais pas ce que israëlle peut
réaliser je n'en sais rien vraiment là
je
euh je nous verrons nous verrons la
campagne militaire ce qu'elle donnera et
ce quels seront les objectifs que pourra
atteindre atteindre Israël mais pour le
moment je n' je suis incapable de de de
de dire quelque chose qui me semble qui
me semble intelligent sur cette question
sur les Américains si vous voulez bien
peut-être l'administration bon ce que
nous ce que ce que nous ont révélé les
événements c'est d'abord un événement
fondamental on ne fait pas pression sur
Israël on n'oblige pas Israël à faire ce
qu'Israël ne veut pas ça c'est quelque
chose de notamment lorsque la sécurité
du pays est en jeu et on le voit bien
donc les États-Unis qui ont une longue
expérience d'Israël ont adopté une
stratégie vous savez c'était de dire
nous allons vous prouver que nous sommes
votre meilleur ami dans l'espoir
qu'ensuite vous nous fassiez confiance
et que l'on puisse influencer votre
politique donc ça a été livraison
désarmement soutien politique envoie de
deux groupes de de groupes aéronavales
en Méditerranée en Méditerranée
orientale mais voilà cela étant de
nouveau Israël ira jusqu'au bout jusqu'à
ce qu'il considère que ses objectifs
militaires et politiques ont été
atteints et je ne sais pas quels sont
ses intérêts politiques et militaires
donc on voit bien ce sont c'est toute la
limite de ce que la communauté
internationale je parle des États-Unis
al par essayer d'imaginer les Européens
qui n'ont pas la moindre influence à à à
à Jérusalem mais ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis parce que ça va ça aggrave
encore si j'ose dire la situation du
président sortant pour les élections qui
viennent en novembre 2024 c'est pour la
première fois la division profonde du
Parti démocrate qui jusque-là le soutien
Israël était un soutien unanime
transpartisan hein républicain démocrate
et là vous avez la gauche démocrate qui
révèle si j'ose dire qu'il a qu'il y a
eu une véritable mutation en son sein et
qu'elle est devenue portant des une
sympathie à la cause à la cause
palestinienne et donc tout ceci va
s'ajoute après la guerre en Ukraine
s'ajoute à toutes les difficultés qui
vont peser sur Joe Biden sur sa capacité
à réunir l'ensemble de la gauche
c'est-à-dire en terme américain à faire
voter et notamment à faire voter les
jeunes euh à le faire se déplacer les
jeunes ça ajoute certainement au aux
nombreuses difficultés à laquelle fait
face la candidature actuellement de de
Joe
Biden sur
le sur les les questions françaises et
européennes comment analysez-vous euh
ce le passé de notre
politique sur le Moyen-Orient sur Israël
on on a quand même eu des interventions
extrêmement lourdes depuis le début
depuis la création de l'État d'Israël on
a contribué
fortement à l'équipement y compris
nucléaire
euh Chun c'est bien que le gouvernement
de Monsieur bourgess monori pour ne pas
le quand j'avais vu le président Peres
et quand on évoquait le nom de brogess
monori c'était
aussitôt un sentiment de de de de
reconnaissance car effectivement la 4e
République a construit en réalité la
force de dissuasion après avant de la
reprocher au général le Gaulle et et
avait notamment passer à aux Israéliens
tout un ensemble d'informations et de de
moyens qui lu ont permis de s'équiper on
a eu ça on a eu les déclaration du
général de Gaulle la politique du
général de gaaule à partir notamment de
la guerre euh de des 6 jours et on a eu
ce qu'on savait moins le le maintien ce
que de d'une liaison épistolaire assez
régulière entre le président Ben Gouron
et le général de Gaulle puisque le
général de Gaulle a reçu une lettre de
Ben Gouron le lendemain de sa mort il y
a une lettre qui est parvenue dans dans
l'échange de correspondance donc tout ça
était très après nous avons
effectivement eu des des engagements
très très précis nous avons conduit les
Européens à é la déclaration de Venise
les les deux états nous avons joué un
rôle important le président Chirac a été
très actif et a laissé un souvenir assez
impressionnant de de de
d'agacement vis-à-vis de des autorités
israéliennes quand il s'est promené à
Jérusalem le président Sarkozi a fait un
discours à la cesset qui est un discours
assez en en pointe quand même bon tout
ça a existé tout ça c'est évolu comment
vous l'analysez comment vous l'analysez
pour le passé pour le présent et pour
l'avenir alors vous de nouveau je ne
vais pas faire l'historique du
l'historique des relations franco
israélienne dans laquelle je me suis
plongé d'ailleurs dans laquelle je me
suis plongé faudra lire votre livre
alors pourir la réponse mais à000homme
en entre en en en réalité lorsque je
suis arrivé en Israël comme ambassadeur
en en en 2003 j'étais chargé par d'une
mission vraiment j'avais des
instructions très claires de de de
Jacques Chirac et de domin de Villepin
de tout faire pour améliorer les
relations bilatérales entre Israël et la
France des relations qui étaient très
dégradées parce que vous savez très bien
on parle de la politique arabe de la
France par définition si c'est une
politique arabe de la France les
Israéliens ne prennent pas très bien il
faut bien dire et donc nous avons
toujours dit nous avons une politique é
équilibrée alors elle était équilibrée
vue de Paris mais elle n'était pas du
tout équilibrée vue de Jérusalem en
d'autres termes l'État d'Israël
considérait que la France était une
puissance inamicale c'était très clair
il n'y avait pas dit et lorsque je suis
arrivé en Israël en 2003 avec Dominque
de vilpin avait signé un accord cadre
pour améliorer les relations
franco-israéliennes c'était donc une
décision très très forte de la France on
l'oublie souvent parce que on on
Nimagine pas que Dominique vilpin est
Jacques chirx c'est paladin du gaulisme
et pu être les les acteurs d'une
amélioration de la relation bilatérale
en réalité oui ils l'ont été et et et
donc je suis arrivé avec ces
instructions très positives et je me
suis rendu compte à quel point pour les
Israéliens d'une certaine manière le
divorce était consommé euh et ce que
nous avons réussi à faire c'est
transformer un divorce
acrimonieux en un divorce je dirais je
ne sais pas si un divorce peut-être
amical mais en tout cas euh moins pour
c'était très clair pour les Israéliens
les la France était une puissance
pro-arabe favorable au palestinien et
donc n'était pas un adversaire d' un
adversaire
d'Israël alors de toute façon de toute
façon pour les Israéliens il faut bien
dire si j'étais si j'avais été israélien
j'aurais un peu réagi de la même manière
en disant bah voilà il y a un médiateur
le médiateur c'est les États-Unis parce
que à la fois que c'est quand même le un
médiateur extrêmement puissant et en
plus c'est un médiateur qui est
extrêmement amical pour Israël donc d'un
point de vue d'intérêt national
israélien l'intérêt national israélien
était de la médiation américaine et
surtout ne rien à voir avec ces
Européens qui vont venir d'une manière
ou d'une autre soutenir les Palestiniens
ou la cause
palestinienne il y a un déséquilibre qui
est en notre faveur et nous n'allons
certainement pas aider à le à le
modifier et donc la relation je dirais
que que malgré malgré nos nos efforts
malgré il y a eu la visite de François
miteran auparavant il y a eu ensuite en
effet le discours de Monsieur de Nicolas
Sarkozi malgré tous ces efforts je
dirais que la relation
franco-israélienne est restée une
relation relativement tiède il n'y a pas
relativement tiède d'une certaine
manière les Israéliens sont passés à
autre chose après avoir connu cette lune
de miel franco-israélienne
extraordinaire qui s'étend jusque en
gros de 1940 à à 19 1949 pardon jusqu'en
1967 c'était l'époque l'armée
israélienne était armée de de mirage de
mirage on comme on on m'a dit en Israël
en 82 quand la première fois que j'y
suis allé on dansait en français à Tel
Aviv avant 1967 et donc 67 c'est le
moment où la France de la résistance aux
yeux des Israéliens devient la France de
Vichi l'histoire d'un seul coup est
changé très naturel très très
naturellement symbolisé par de Gaul en
plus avec symbolisé avec la fameuse
phrase du général qui était un
compliment dans les sur les lèvres du
général mais voilà donc une je dirais
une relation
franco-israélienne qui est de nouveau
qui du côté d'Israël a pendant très
longtemps nous a vu pendant très
longtemps plutôt comme un une puissance
un pays inamical qui pour des raisons
mercantiles était vendu au pétrole arabe
je caricature à peine depuis le depuis
donc la décision de de Jacques Chirac de
domin vilpin reprise et poursuivie et
amplifié par Nicolas Sarkozi mais
ensuite poursuivi par François Hollande
et par Emmanuel Macron je dirais que nos
relations sont devenues des relations
d'état à état des relations plutôt
plutôt tièdes avec une avec une question
supplémentaire naturellement pour
l'ambassadeur qui est l'importance de la
communauté expatrier la communauté
franco-israélienne donc moi quand
j'étais en Israël en 19 s en 2006 à la
fin il y avait à peu près 90000
franco-israéliens aujourd'hui on est
sans doute aux environs de
180000 parce qu'il y a eu une
accélération de l'alia la montée en
Israël essentiellement dû
essentiellement d tout simplement hélas
à la montée de des actes antisémites en
France c'està dire on peut quasiment
établir une corrélation entre un acte
antisémite grave et il y en a eu die
sais s'il y a eu d'actes antisémite
grave hein c'est selon nous on meurt on
est mort en France parce que parce que
juif donc l'école aeratora le
l'hypercacher les assassin Dylan Alimi
Sarah Alimi
mol tout ça à chaque fois on a quasiment
une augmentation de l'alia de l'alia par
exemple entre 2014 et
2016 avec les attentats que vous
connaissez il y a eu plus de 20000000
juifs français qui sont qui ont fait
leur allas qui sont allés en en en
Israël plus de 20000 donc ça aussi c'est
un élément dans naturellement un élément
dans la dans la relation bilatérale que
le l'ambassadeur doit gérer et et ce
n'est pas le plus
simple je vous remercie de ces ces ces
éclairages extrêmement intéressant euh
maintenant ce sont les les représentants
des groupes qui vont s'exprimer et le
premier ce sera pour le groupe
Renaissance monsieur Viber donc 2
minutes et demi et vous tâchez de
répondre dans des des limites
comparables sachant que je n'ai aucun
pouvoir sur
vous brancher mon MICR ah pardon pardon
c'est moi voilà merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je vous
remercie pour votre exposé concernant la
situation actuelle au Proche-Orient la
France a souvent joué un rôle de
médiateur et de facilitateur dans les
négociations entre Israéliens et
Palestiniens elle a soutenu les efforts
internationaux visant à parvenir à une
solution négociée et pacifique notre
pays a maintenu une position constante
en faveur de la solution à deux états
considéré comme la voie la plus viable
pour résoudre le conflit en
reconnaissant les aspirations légitimes
des deux parties dans une démarche
constructive elle a parfois lancé des
initiatives diplomatiques indépendantes
pour relancer les pour parler de paix
face à l'impasse du processus de paix la
France a organisé une conférence
ministérielle pour la paix au
Proche-Orient en juin 2016 en présence
d'une trentaine d'états et
d'organisations internationales afin de
renouveler la mobilisation de la comm é
internationale et de relancer une
dynamique de paix dans la continuité de
cette initiative s'est tenue le 15
janvier 2017 à Paris la conférence
internationale pour la paix au Proche
Orient à laquelle plus de 70 États ont
participé l'objectif était triple
réaffirmer la nécessité de mettre en
œuvre la solution des deux états pour
établir une paix durable assurer la
détermination de la communauté
internationale à contribuer à la paix au
proche- Orient présenter des pistes
d'action pour poursuivre la mobilisation
sur le long terme par ailleurs la France
en tant que membre permanent du Conseil
de sécurité de l'ONU a également joué un
rôle dans les discussions et les
résolutions lié au conflit
israélo-palestinien au sein de cette
instance internationale en plus de son
rôle au Conseil de sécurité la France a
également contribué à des missions de
maintien de la paix et d'observation
dans la région soutenant ainsi les
efforts de stabilisation et de
prévention des
conflits Monsieur l'Ambassadeur quelle
évaluation feriez-vous des médiations
impliquant la France et quels
enseignements pouvons-nous en tirer quel
rôle la France peut-elle jouer au sein
des instances international tel que
l'ONU pour favoriser une résolution
juste et durable du conflit je vous
remercie Monsieur l'Ambassadeur monsieur
le député la réunion à laquelle vous
faites allusion au début 2017 est un
événement assez curieux parce que
c'était une conférence de paix à
laquelle n'assistaiit ni les États-Unis
ni l'État d'Israël
euh parce que figurez-vous que Donald
Trump venait d'être élu et
les l'administration Trump m'avait fait
m'avait avait demandé à me voir à la
fameuse tour Trump et m'avait dit bah
vous voulez organiser une conférence
nous on arrive on ne connaît pas on ne
connaît pas encore les dossiers on ne
sait pas comment comment agir donc on
vous demande de la reporter ce qui je
dois vous l'avouer de mon côté me
semblait être du bon sens la conférence
a eu lieu et donc sans les Américains et
et sans les Israéliens euh et je ne sais
pas à quoi elle a elle a pu elle a pu
servir au fond essayons de de nous
projeter dans l'avenir euh de nous
projeter dans l'avenir et de se de nous
dire comment pouvons-nous relancer la la
processus de paix si vous me permettez
de faire un petit peu moi j'aurais
tendance à dire les deux parties sont
incapables d'aller à la paix par
elles-même les deux parties par
elles-même hein vous avez d'abord
négocier avec qui vous avez d'un côté un
gouvernement d'extrême droite qui ne
veut pas lâcher Laas Jordanie dans les
faite de l'autre côté vous avez le Hamas
on va pas négocier avec le Hamas et donc
ça veut dire qu'il faut une mobilisation
de la communauté internationale il faut
les pays arabes les pays européens d'une
certainer manière de qui qui soient
capable de dire aux Israéliens et aux
Palestiniens bah voilà si vous vous
asseyez autour de la même table et bien
nous nous pouvons vous apporter ça nous
pouvons vous dire les Arabes
reconstruction de du des de Gaza les
Arabes disons aux Israéliens vous serez
une part intégrante de de cette de cette
région les Européens voyez on peut
essayer pour essayer de convaincre des
gens qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas vraiment
pas envie de s'asseoir autour de la même
table de s'asseoir autour de la même
table mais pour et pour ça la France
peut agir mais ça voudrait dire qu'elle
agisse discrètement et et je crains que
ce ne soit pas un des talents principaux
de la diplomatie française et euh et
doncés allons allons non de nouveau je
n'attaque pas le je n'attaque pas le le
le tout le monde pense je je je critique
le président de la République non
personne ne l'a pensé parce que vous
êtes vous avez bon esprit vous avez bon
esprit et c'est bien non mais plus
sérieusement j'aurais tendance à dire ça
a toujours été un peu le cas de la
diplomatie française on adore monter sur
la sur la scène mais quit à recevoir des
tomates il y a une vanité de la
diplomatie française et donc si l'on
veut travailler vousz au socialiste sil
si l'on veut travailler je pense que bah
voilà il faut aller prendre la canne sa
canne son chapeau ses gamburf et vous
allez voir discrètement les souiens les
émiratis vous allez voir les Américains
en disant bah alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire voyez il faut être imaginatif
pourquoi pas associer la Palestine
Israël et la Jordanie à à l'Union
européenne une un accord d'association
d'association madame la députée pas de
pas de membre de un accord
d'association on peut également
réfléchir par rapport aux relations avec
l'OTAN puisque pour les Israéliens la
sécurité et l'obsession ESS essayons
d'être imaginatif mais de nouveau il
faut le faire dans la plus grande
discrétion vous avez une chance sur 100
de réussir
voilà on est toujours ramené à Pascal
Paris pascalien euh pour le
rassemblement national c'est la
présidente Le Pen qui oui Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur de France euh depuis
l'udiose attaque d'Israël par le Hamas
le 7 octobre dernier qui a fait plus de
1400 morts dans une quarantaine tout de
même de nos compatriotes il m'apparaît
et j'imagine que c'est le cas de
nombreux pays euh qui sont parties
prenantes dans cette région que la voix
de la France est particulièrement
confuse nous cantonnons ainsi à une
forme de passivité alors que hier encore
la diplomatie française aurait eu j'ose
l'espérer un rôle d'intermédiation d'un
soutien incondnel à Israël à une
exhortation à cesser les bombardements
passant par une coalition internationale
pour lutter contre le Hamas plus
personne ne suit la fameuse pensée
complexe du président de la République
si mal adapté à l'Orient compliqué où il
faut voler avec des idées simples je
crois au contraire j'ai le l'occasion de
le développer encore récemment que la
constance est une vertu cardinale en
diplomatie la constance c'est pas de
commenter au jour le jour la riposte
légitime d'Israël pour éradiquer le
mouvement terroriste du Hamas mais de
continuer malgré son caractère quasi
réaliste du fait et vous l'avez rappelé
du traumatisme vécu par les israëlien à
promouvoir une solution politique pour
cette région qui est le berceau nous le
savons de tant de civilisations
l'objectif de cette solution nous la
connaissons c'est encore la position de
la France et deux états dans les
frontières reconnues comme j'ai dit le
peuple israélien et le peuple
palestinien mérit considér et respect et
défenseur farouche de l'égalité en
dignité et en droit de tous les peuples
et toutes les nations je pense que la
reconnaissance de ces principes par les
acteurs est un préalable nécessaire pour
relancer les négociations vers cet
objectif au combien ambitieux là encore
vous avez appuyé sur cette difficulté
mais je crois incontournable de la paix
dans cette région alors nonobstant les
propos désespérant ou désespéré je sais
pas que vous avez tenu mais qui sont on
veut le croire
conjoncturel les les pays arabes et vous
l'avez un peu évoqué ont-ils vraiment la
capacité de venir politiquement à bout
du
hamass et et si oui qui et au bénéfice
de qui et est-ce que ça n'est pas là la
condition en réalité nécessaire même si
elle n'est pas suffisante à une
potentielle relance d'un processus de
paix c'est ma première question la
deuxième qui est un peu plus large à la
lumière de votre très longue expérience
pourriez-vous nous éclairer sur ce
qu'attendent de la France les pays du
Proche
Orient
je vous remercie madame le député
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur si vous voulez
répondre à Madame Le Pen
naturellement madame madame la
Présidente donc comme je l'ai dit les
pays arabes au fond ont noué dans les
fêtes une alliance avec Israël car le
fondement même des relations
internationales c'est l'ennemi mon
ennemi et mon ami il y a un ennemi
commun c'est l'Iran et donc les
monarchie du golf et l'Égypte sont sont
travaille étroitement avec Israël
vaille étroitement avec Israël notamment
dans les domaines sécuritaires c'était
les accords d'Abraham c'est quand même
une réussite américaine ça permet aux
États-Unis d'une certaine manière de se
retirer de la région et Israël prend la
place de garant de la sécurité des
monarchies du golf face face à l'Iran et
c'est ce qu'aujourd'hui Israël est bel
et bien le garant de la sécurité des
monarchies du golf face à l'Iran vous
avez raison de souligner il y a je crois
qu'il y a deux conditions nécessaires
pour relancer pour essayer de essayons
de de de regarder l'avenir relancer le
processus de paix le premier comme je
l'ai dit c'est rassurer l'opinion
publique israélienne c'est de convaincre
l'opinion publique israélienne
que dans le processus de paix qui
s'engagerait euh sa sécurité serait
assuré et et c'est c'est vraiment un
vrai défi c'est un vrai défi et deuxè
2uxè condition c'est faire apparaître un
leadership qui soit un leadership
démocratique et un leadership euh qui
soit euh prêt à s'engager dans une
logique de paix du côté des Palestiniens
et euh et voilà c'est et et vous et euh
je n'ai pas besoin de vous le souligner
à quel point ce sont deux conditions
énormes et extrêmement difficiles est-ce
qu'il est possible parce que du côté
palestinien vous avez donc d'un côté le
Hamas qui à l'évidence quoi qu'on pense
par ailleurs à l'évidence ne peut ne
sera pas accepté comme un un
interlocuteur par Israël et de l'autre
côté vous avez une Autorité
palestinienne alors disons que les
Israéliens ont leur responsabilité
là-dedans mais une Autorité
palestinienne qui est totalement
discréditée qui est corrompu inefficace
et qui ne représente plus plus les
Israéliens est-ce que l'on peut faire
apparaître les Palestiniens pardon
est-ce qu'on peut faire apparaître une
un leadership
euh ça je n'en sais rien est-ce que
c'est possible vous savez c'est la
situation est est beaucoup plus
paradoxale et contradictoire qu'on le
pense par exemple la plupart des des la
plupart je suis presque sûr que
quasiment tous les Palestiniens de s
Jordanie parlent couramment l'hébreux
que ils regardent la télévision
israélienne plutôt que la trélvision
palestinienne voyez donc il y a aussi
puis vous a il y a aussi du côté des des
Palestiniens il y a aussi une fatigue
ils ont vraiment moi je connais pas mal
de jeunes Palestiniens de pas de Gaza
j'ai jamais eu le droit d'y aller mais
de de en sisjordanie ou en gros d'une
certaine manière ils n'en peuvent plus
ils en ont assez ils aimeraient
atteindre ils aimeraient connaître une
normalité une vie normale et d'ailleurs
la plupart ne croi même plus à la
solution des deux étatsin c'est même ils
sont même à force de voir des à force de
voir des des grues sur toutes les les
les les les implantations israéliennes
ils se disent bah ils vont pas partir
hein et les Arabes nous ont abandonné
parce que les pays arabes ont totalement
abandonné la cause palestinienne nous
sommes tous seuls le PIB d'Israël c'est
25 fois le PIB des territoires
palestiniens donc voilà le rapport de
force est sans est sans appel donc donc
est-ce que l'on peut utiliser est-ce
qu'on peut permettre l'émergence d'un
d'un leadership palestinien évidemment
je n'en sais rien mais ce ce serait
c'est une une condition nécessaire parce
que sans si vous n'avez pas
d'interlocuteur mais alors la condition
nécessaire donc réussir à avoir
l'émergence d'un d'un leadership
palestinien et peut-être que les
Européens pourraient jouer un rôle he
nous les connaissons quand même tous ces
Palestiniens puisque et et de l'autre
côté il faut aussi du côté israélien il
faut aussi voir un interlocuteur qui
veuilleent qui veilleent négocier et qui
veilleent négocier sur la base de la
solution des deux états et on n est pas
à l'heure actuelle avec le gouvernement
actuel on en est on en est on en est
encore loin donc vous comprenez
peut-être les raisons de mon désespoir
oui nous avons fait venir pour nous
guérir de notre désespoir et vous nous
faites bénéficier du fait que vous
partagez la l'anxiété d'une grande
partie des membres de cette commission
euh je je je vais maintenant donner la
parole à la pour la France insoumise à à
Monsieur
legal merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur merci pour votre
exposé la situation concernant notamment
la sis Jordanie vous avez employé des
mots forts vous avez même parler de
nettoyage ethnique au
détail vous avez aussi évoqué votre
sentiment de blocage puisquil y a
finalement deux formes de de de de
fusion entre nationalisme et religion
qui s'oppose que soit le Hamas ou que
soit le gouvernement d'extrême droite
d'Israël et euh vous vous vous vous avez
exposé votre votre scepticisme sur la
possibilité de réanimer l'Autorité
palestinienne mais malgré tout je me
permets de vous relancer sur ce sujet
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire parce
queil y a pas il faut des interlocuteur
pour la paix et à l'heure actuelle les
les principaux protagonistes ne sont pas
pour la paix par ailleurs vous
avez fait part d'une relative d'un
relatif optimiste sur les les risques
d'extension du conflit malgré tout
est-ce que vous pourriez revenir sur la
situation au Sud Liban on a quand même
700 soldats français sur place c'est
très tendu donc est-ce que vous vous
avez des craintes sur l'extension de la
guerre au Sud Liban par ailleurs vous
avez rappelé qu'en 2003 à votre
nomination vous aviez une ligne de route
qui était d'essayer de rétablir des
relations meilleures avec Israël vous
rappeleiez la la tiédeur des relations
au passage ça montre qu'on peut être
pour une solution à deux états et ne pas
être anti-israélien puisque c'était une
feuille de route donnée par Chirac et et
Dominique de vil
je rappelle quand même queauparavant un
président comme le président miteran
pouvait à la fois aller à l'anné 7
donner tout son soutien à Israël et à la
fois et non pas en même temps
euh demander la création d'un État
palestinien et il a lui-même joué un
rôle dans dans les accords de slow donc
cette ligne avait aussi quand même du
sens dans le contexte actuel par rapport
à cette ligne comment perceevez-vous les
frictions qui semblent exister au
ministère des Affaires étrangères je
renvoie notamment à la lettre de
certains ambassadeurs qui créent crne la
disparition d'une voie alternative de la
France qu'est-ce que ça veut dire quelle
serait cette voie
alternative et enfin derrière en effet
peut-être une certaine illisibilité de
la la position française il y a quand
même des des moments où le président a
dit certaines choses il a notamment
parler d'un cesser le
feu je dois dire que je suis assez
étonné que de navoir entendu aucune
réponse officielle après les accusation
d'antisémitisme contre le président de
la République sur une chaîne en
français comment interprétez-vous cela
et vous en tant qu'ambassadeur comment
auriez-vous réagi dans le dans dans dans
dans cette situation merci il y a
beaucoup de questions qui sont posées
par Monsieur legal donc je vais pas vous
enfermer dans les 2 minutes et demi là
ça serait vraiment ça sera vraiment
impossible je suis à peu près sûr que je
vais en oublier mais ce n'est pas la
mauvaise volonté il faud c'est l'âge et
donc je vais essayer de alors les
étatdames des des diplomates bon les
diplomates ont souvent des état d'âme
hein nous sommes une catégorie un peu
fragile psychologiquement dans fragile
nous sommes un peu des vieilles dames
mais
euh en réalité c'est notre travail vous
savez le travail des haut-fonctionnaires
c'est de de dire au au au pouvoir
politique de dire au pouvoir politique
voilà ce que je pense être la bonne
politique et ensuite c'est le pouvoir
politique qui tranche moi il m'est
arrivé euh pas pas souvent mais il m'est
arrivé de de de proposer une politique
de ne pas être suivi par le pouvoir
politique et ensuite bah de le mettre en
œuvre de mettre en œuvre avec toute ma
loyauté et ma
une politique que je n'approuvais pas
c'est ça la démocratie c'est le le
ministre qui décide et donc les les
ambassadeurs ont parfaitement le droit
de de critiquer ou voilà moi ce qu'on me
dit c'est que en réalité cette note
était une note interne qu'elle a été
écrite avec par des ambassadeurs
c'est-à-dire que ce n'est pas du tout un
brûlau c'est avec toutes les précautions
il faudrait des nuances enfin ça fait
partie un petit peu de la je dirais du
fonctionnement normal d'un ministère et
que cette note a été évidemment rendue
publique par trois ambassadeurs à la
retraite et par un journaliste voilà
mais moi pour moi ça exprime assez bien
le fonctionnement normal d'un ministère
où on a le droit on a le devoir de dire
de dire ce qu'on
pense sur le fond de nouveau j'ai je
n'ai pas lu la note euh mais je comme je
l'ai dit au
début honnêtement le problème avec le
monde arabe comme je l'ai dit c'est les
gouvern les États sont avec Israël donc
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire est-ce que
notre problème c'est l'opinion publique
mais dans un État autoritaire que
doit-être la politique étrangère de la
France la politique étrangère c'est
quand même les relation avec les états
euh enfin voilà donc je mais de nouveau
je n'ai pas lu je n'ai pas lu cette je
n'ai pas lu cette note je n'ai pas je
voilà en ce qui concerne de nouveau vous
savez
euh il y a je dirais il y a un narratif
français hein sur notre politique la
politique arabe la politique équilibrée
la politique et comme je l'ai dit le
problème c'est que un des une des deux
parties ne considérait pas du tout cette
politique comme équilibrée euh
vraimement vraiment vous savez quand
j'ai passé 6 6 ans de ma vie en Israël
en Israël alors maintenant c'est moins
le cas c'était quasiment un comment
pourrait-on dire un lieu commun de dire
les Français la France est
anti-israélienne même les les
francophiles le disait
voyez les francophiles le disaient en
disant notre notre cisme mercantil
c'était pour vendre des mirages que nous
avions vendu notre âme et pour avoir du
pétrole voyez donc donc je me méfie
toujours de cette idée une sorte de
comment pourrait-on dire d'idéalisation
d'un
passé nous avons nous avions une
politique qui je dirais d'un d'une
manière un peu brutale avait son intérêt
parce que comme ça ça nous permettait
d'avoir de bonnes relations et pas
seulement pour la vente de mirage avec
le avec le monde arabe nous avons
peut-être
aussi servi de SAS si si j'ose dire pour
la reconnaissance de l'OLP on oublie on
oublie que l'OLP vous savez c'est c'est
quand même c'était une situation
noublion pas que pendant jusque dans les
années 80 voir au-delà des Israéliens
disaient au gouvernement il n'y a pas de
peuple palestinien quand même hein donc
la négation était des deux côtés il y
avait une un négationnisme des deux
côtés donc c'est c'est vrai que le fait
de recevoir Arafat à Paris le fait
d'accepter qu'il y ait un bureau l'OLP à
Paris d'une certaine manière ça amené le
glissement d'Arafat vers l'acceptation
mais soyons franc en réalité la France
n'était qu'une étape pour Arafat
l'objectif d'Arafat c'était Washington
voilà donc on a on a pe on a joué on
peut dire que c'est ce rôle a été joué
mais ne disons pas que nous avons été un
médiateur entre les deux parties parce
que les Israéliens ne voulaient vraiment
pas ne voulaient vraiment pas de nous
pour la relance du processus de paix
comme je l'ai dit je pense que étant
donné le blocage des deux parties il
faudrait mobiliser tout le monde comme
voilà j'ai dit les pays arabes qu'est-ce
que peuvent apporter les pays arabes euh
jusque-là les pays arabes d'ailleurs
comme le reste de la communauté
internationale se disait le problème
résolu le problème est résolu Israël a
gagné les Palestiniens vont plus ou
moins voilà euh et ce qui compte c'est
l'ennemi iranien et voilà le 7 octobre
nous a prouvé que ce choix du statut quo
euh n'était pas le bon mais donc à
ramener le dossier du processus de paix
sur la table mais le problème c'est
qu'il n'y a personne pour se saisir du
dossier
aujourd'hui ni les Israéliens ni les
Palestiniens est-ce que au sein de la
communauté internationale on s'en
saisira et là hélas c'est vraiment je
suis je suis pessimiste mais hélas vous
avez deux problèmes contre contre cette
hypothèse vous avez d'un côté les
États-Unis qui rentrent en campagne
électorale alors vous imaginez bien que
vous n'allez pas vooir un président
Biden qui va s'impliquer dans un
processus de paix qui tôt ou tard le
mettra en comment dire avec Israël en
difficulté avec une partie du
gouvernement israélien et de l'autre
vous avez la Russie qui a évidemment
intérêt à souffler sur les braises pour
la Russie ce conflit est un don est un
don des dieux et d'ailleurs la les
Russes en profitent en profitent
abondamment sur le thème du de poid sur
le thème du deux poids de mesure donc et
c'est pour ça que il y a petit espoir je
ne veux quand même pas vous vous
désespérer un petit espoir que pourquoi
pas la France pourrait de nouveau
discrètement essayer de renouer les fils
par rapport à toutes les parties toutes
les parties qui peuvent être intéressé à
au défaut de résoudre ce conflit au
moins à préparer une étape une étape
Pacifique j'ai dû oublier quelque chose
non oui le
Liban le alors le Liban alors le Liban
c'est vous avez d'abord le hzbolah
évidemment est un est en dépend
étroitement du de l'Iran mais le le
hbola n'est pas une annexe des services
iraniens il y a quand même une autonomie
du du du hbola le hbola a quand même son
autonomie mais le le hbola a une mémoire
et cette mémoire enfin moi je ça j'ai
j'ai vécu ça j'étais encore ambassadeur
c'est l'opération 2006 en 2006 les le
hbollah a fait une opération qui elle
aussi a été un succès infiniment moins
sanglante puisque une une attaque du
hzbolah a tué je crois neu soldats
israéliens et ce qui a déclenché ce qui
a déclenché en juillet 2006 une
opération militaire et cette opération
militaire a
été je dirais a eu des cûs des coûts
extrêmement lourds pour la population
civile du Liban au point que nasrala le
le patron du du hzbollah a même présenté
des excuses à à au au au sud libanais et
là on a on s bien dans tout le Liban un
cri unique sur le thème n'y allez pas
nous ne voulons pas la guerre ne nous
entraîz pas dans une guerre qui serait
évidemment extrêmement coûteuse et le
hzbolah contrairement au Hamas qui a des
visions califales le Hezbollah c'est
vraiment un parti politique libanais
n'est-ce pas c'est vraiment le
représentant d'une communauté qui il
faut bien dire était une communauté
défavorisée dans le partage dans le
partage du pouvoir à beyouth et donc
voilà c'est euh euh en même temps vous
allez vous avez et d'ailleurs le hesbola
euh de manière très ce que moi j'appelle
dans not dans le beau métier diplomate
là le kaboui vous savez on crie mais on
ne fait rien le hzbola avait a tiré mais
at tiré non pas sur le territoire
d'Israël mais sur les fermes de Sheba
qui est un territoire contesté ce qui
permet à au au hzbollah de dire voyez
j'ai tiré mais en même temps de dire aux
Israéliens en chuchautant mais pas sur
pas par sur Israël donc je pense que
l'esbolah veut éviter d'y aller mais il
y a évidemment au Sud Liban des
mouvements palestiniens il y a notamment
le Djihad islamique qui lui a tout
intérêt à provoquer une montée une
montée en puissance et un affrontement
un affrontement et donc nous il le
risque existe que euh de de de de
missile en missile de de tir en tir que
l'on arrive on arrive en effet à un
affrontement sur nos soldats en au Sud
Liban je dois avouer que ça fait 20 ans
je me demande ce qu'ils y font hein mais
euh
ça c'est voilà c'est une fois qu'on
envoie des soldats on peut plus les
retirer c'est une c'est quelque chose
d'important mais ils ont vu passer comme
ça pendant 40 ans les Israéliens le
hzbollah les Iraniens sans pouvoir rien
faire et donc je me pose toujours la
j'ai toujours posé la question et on m'a
toujours regardé avec de grands yeux au
Koré lorsque je posais lorsque je posais
la question euh et je ne répondrai pas
sur le président de la République vous
avez raison ne serait-ce que parce que
vous avez déjà utilisé 9 minutes pardon
non mais c'est très
bien maintenant la la pour les
républicains c'est Monsieur Herbillon
qui va prendre la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur de votre présence de vos
analyses qui sont extrêmement pertinent
et et c'est un bonheur pour notre
commission de pouvoir vous auditionner
ce matin je voulais vous interroger à
mon tour sur l'horizon politique de la
situation au Proche-Orient mais vous y
avez à ment répondu mais je voudrais
faire référence à vos à vos vos écrits
et votre connaissance de l'histoire de
l'histoire des conflits de l'histoire
diplomatique peut-être ça nous donnera
une lueur d'espoir et sans vous
transformer en prévisionniste ou en
madame yma ne pensez-vous pas quand même
que la communauté internationale dans
son ensemble contte tenu du degré de
violence que connaît le conflit et de
l'ancienneté de ce conflit à aura pour
souvent un thème que vous utiliser pour
décrire les relations internationales ce
sera l'intérêt de la communauté
internationale que de trouver une
solution que d'avoir un horizon
politique parce que pour à pour à la
fois pour les États-Unis pour l'Europe
pour les pays arabes la situation ne
peut pas continuer comme cela parce que
sinon il n'y a aucune raison que la
prochaine fois ce ne soit pas un degré
de violence encore supplémentaire et je
voudrais aussi profiter euh je voudrais
vous questionner au sujet de l'Arabie
Saoudite parce que et avoir votre grille
d'analyse parce que dans le même temps
où l'Arabie Saoudite s'apprêtait à
signer les accords d'Abraham avec Israël
elle se rapproché de l'Iran sous la
houlette de la Chine et je voudrais
avoir votre gr d'analyse sur cette
situationl comp tenu du rôle important
euh euh historique et et et religieux
qu'occupe l'Arabie Saoudite et enfin je
voudrais profiter si le président m'y
autorise et il m'autorise généralement
euh euh de vot d'une double opportunité
d'abord votre présence et je le dis dans
l'ordre et d'autre part la rencontre
entre le président XI et le président
Biden pour vous interroger sur un autre
sujet parce que en vérité ce qui
intéresse les États-Unis c'est la
confrontation avec la Chine et ce qui
intéresse la Chine c'est la
confrontation avec les États-Unis
notamment celle qui s'exerce dans
l'Indo-Pacifique dans euh en Asie et je
voudrais avoir votre grille d'analyse
sur ce qui se passe là-bas parce que on
a euh des Sit d'abord la France est
présente parce que c'est un pays de
l'Indo-Pacifique donc quel rôle peut
jouer la France on assiste à des choses
tout à fait étrange comme avec
l'Australie qui à la fois nous a viré
pour signer locus mais qui maintenant se
se rapproche de la Chine euh puisque euh
il y a un voyage sujet mais pas mais pas
hors tempsou non voilà pas hors temps ça
rassurez-vous j'ai voilà donc je
voudrais avoir votre euh sachant que il
y a un certain nombre de pays asiatiques
qui ne veulent pas cette confrontation
et que la France pourrait jouer là le
rôle d'équilibre qui est
traditionnellement celui que la France
veut occuper monsieur monsieur Herbillon
est l'un de nos peut-être le principal
spécialiste de cette commission de
l'Indo-Pacifique et Monsieur le monsieur
le le député je dois vous avouer que
pour moi la question que vous avez posé
c'est franchement la vraie question
l'avenir du monde va se définir entre la
New Delhi et Los Angeles et pour les
États-Unis cétait évident que la guerre
en Ukraine est une distraction au sens
anglais du au sens américain du du mot
distraction les États-Unis étaient sur
était en train de quitter l'Europe sur
la pointe des pieds Poutine les a
rattrapés par les Basques mais c'est
vraiment c'est là car c'est en Asie
qu'il y a la croissance les
potentialités de croissance he nous en
Europe nous sommes tout fiers quand nous
arrivons à 2 % eux c'est 6 8 % et de
surcroiss c'est là qu'il y a la menace
car il y a la superpuissance la
superpuissance chinoise et nous avons
aujourd'hui une ext extordinaire
géopolitique qui moi je me passionne
mais que voulez-vous je suis en tant
diplomate je suis un vautour qui vit du
malheur des autres et donc qui me
passionne un grand jeu d'équilibre
géopolitique qui se met en place et et
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est une
guerre froide 2.0 c'est-à-dire la
différence essentielle il y a deux
différences essentielles la Chine et les
États-Unis ont un commerce intense et
deuxièmement les pays de la région ne
veulent pas sont pris entre l'enclume et
le marteau ils ne veulent pas choisir
leur camp et c'est vrai que là euh la
France pour devrait pouvoir jouer son
rôle et le président de la République
d'ailleurs le le fait hein le fait en
Inde il le fait en Indonésie aussi il
est allé pour le Pr premier président de
la République à aller aussi au
bangladesch donc là nous avons en effet
un rôle un rôle un rôle à jouer nous
sommes évidemment beaucoup plus proches
des États-Unis que de la Chine mais nous
n'avons pas être aligné sur les
États-Unis dans cette confrontation
globale et de long terme qui se met en
place B je ferme là mais je pourrais en
parler longtemps parce que je sais c'est
un sujet que je trouve absolument
passionnant sur l'Arabie Saoudite là
aussi c'est un sujet très intéressant
l'Arabie saouddite s'est dégagé de la
sphère d'influence américaine voilà la
Mohammed ben Salman s'est dégagé de la
sphère d'influence américaine et prétend
jouer sa propre sa propre partition et
et sa propre partition c'est bon
l'adversaire stratégique c'est l'Iran et
de part et d'autre ils le savent bien
mais comment est-ce que on peut arriver
à un modus vivindiit avec l'Iran et
c'est un petit peu ce que les séouiens
et les Iraniens ont essayé de faire
pourquoi parce que les Iraniens le
régime iranien est quand même en
position de faiblesse du fait de ces de
ces difficultés de ces difficultés
internes et de nouveau l'Arabie Saoudite
ne voulait ne pas dépendre seulement de
la protection américaine ou même de la
protection israélienne j'ai toujours été
assez surpris je l'ai dit à plusieurs
reprises par ces efforts américains de
d'intégrer l'Arabie Saoudite dans les
accords d'Abraham parce que soyons franc
les séouiens et les Israéliens couchent
ensemble depuis 20 ans vraiment moi je
suis allé à Riad j'ai rencontré j'ai
rencontré des Israéliens portant kipa
portant kipa et et visiblement venant
venant avec leur propre avion venant
régulièrement à riade et donc d'une
certaine manière les Américains
demandent que l'on proposer que l'on
officialise une liaison et qu'on en
fasse un mariage mais voilà alors euh et
ce qui fait que les Américains étaient
un peu les demandeurs c'est ça qui était
extraordinaire et que donc déjà aux
États-Unis on s'inquiétait du prix que
les États-Unis allaient payer que
l'administration Biden allait payer
notamment en terme de nucléaire parce
que la l'Arabie Saoudite demandait
l'accès à à la technologie nucléaire par
les de par de par les Américains
l'Arabie Saoudite demandaiit aussi des
livraisons massives d'armes donc on
avait on avait de manière curieuse un
peu surtout les Américains les
Américains étaient plutôt demandeurs
l'Arabie Saoudite s'engageait dans cette
voix sans enthousiasme particulier les
séouiens ont un problème en particulier
qui est le problème du du du du DOM du
Roc mononde du temple puisque ils
prétendent évidemment jouer un rôle un
rôle central dans le monde dans le monde
musulman et donc il s'inquiète toujours
un petit peu de certains projets de de
mouvements ex mouvements extrêmement
marginaux en Israël et et donc ils
hésitaient à il s'hésitaent à s'engager
parce que s'il y avait le moindre
incident ensuite et il y en a des
incidents régulièrement ils auraient été
obligés d'apparaître comme tolérer ou ne
pas tolérer enfin et donc il y avait une
hésitation une évidente hésitation du
côté de Mohamed Ben Salman de s'engager
dans cette dans dans dans cette dans
cette voie mais c'est un changement de
nouveau qu'il y ait comme je l'ai dit
que les séouiens les Israéliens soient
simplement euh ce soit une liaison ou un
mariage la réalité c'est qu'il y a un
véritable alignement géostratégique
entre les monarchies du golf et l'État
d'Israël que cet alignement
géostratégique était dirigé avant tout
contre l'Iran et que maintenant jusque
jusqu'à maintenant il résiste ce qui
prouve qu'il correspond à des réalité
fortes euh alors que l'on bombarde et
que l'on bombarde Gaza et que des
grandes manifestations ont lieu et des
grandes manifestations ont lieu dans les
rues dans les rues des des des pays
arabes je merci je nous nous devons
avancer un peu plus vite excuse-moi non
non il pas du tout c'est passionnant
Monsieur Frédéric petit pour le groupe
modem merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je voudrais
commencer par par noter la la la la
qualité des débats et remercier mon
Président et l'ensemble des collègues
pour la qualité de ces débats qui sont
liés à la qualité à la fluidité de vos
interventions et de vos réponses c'est
extrêmement plaisant vous avez répondu à
la question que je voulais vous poser
vous avez répondu d' manière un peu vous
dites désespéré je dirait pessimiste qui
était sur la 6 Jordanie où je j'ai
souvent considéré moi dans les passages
que j'ai fait dans cette région que
j'étais plus impressionné par la haine
entretenu en sisjordanie qu'à Gaza ou à
Gaza c'était plutôt un problème de
misère je trouvais de de
désorganisation je voudrais donc voilà
vous avez utilisé le mot apathie d'une
partie de l'opinion israélienne qui qui
m'éclaire pas mal que je trouve assez
juste vous avez parlé de statut quo je
je pense quand même que le statut quo
est un statut quo du grignotage donc qui
était pas vraiment un statut quo donc je
suis voilà je sais pas si le le mot
statu quo est le bon dans ce qui est
intéressé voilà mais enfin j'étais vous
avez répondu à cette question je
voudrais puisqu'on a du mal à aller vers
l'avenir il y a deux questions où
j'aimerais votre témoignage qui sont des
questions qui sont plutôt liées à des à
des constats que je voudrais que vous
nous partagiez parce que vous les
connaissez bien
euh puisque de là sur l'avenir je je
voilà
quelle est la solution qui est attendue
de l'autre côté à part faire partir les
Palestiniens j'ai du mal à voir donc je
ne vous interrogerai pas sur l'avenir
vous avez répondu sur le passé la
situation présente j'ai d'abord une
question euh j'étais moi dans j'habitais
dans cette région dans dans les années
2010-25 on a parlé d'un printemps arabe
palestinien qui était un peu sous les
radars quel est votre regard là-dessus
est-ce qu'il y a eu un printemps arabe
palestinien est-ce qu'il y a des des
forces qui ont qui ont émergé est-ce que
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose qui est
resté voilà je je je j'ai eu un un
regard assez lointain mais je voudrais
avoir votre votre regard sur l'existence
réelle d'un printemps arabe palestinien
ou pas et qu'est-ce qu'il en est resté
et deuxièmement une question qui
pourrait paraître éloignée mais qui me
paraît moi parfois centrale surtout pour
un Européen convaincu comment est gérer
l'eau en cjordanie aujourd'hui quels
sont les problèmes liés à l'eau à la
gestion de l'eau aujourd'hui en
sjordanie vu de quelqu'un qui a passé de
longues années sur ce terrain je vous
remercie deux questions précises oui euh
en ce qui concerne
lesond rapidement en ce qui concerne les
Palestiniens comme je l'ai dit
euh je pense que il y a là un terrain de
pour l'Union européenne pour aussi les
parlementaires il y a un terrain pour
essayer justement de prendre de d'avoir
des relations avec une jeune génération
palestinienne je sais qu'elle existe en
Cisjordanie je j'ai rencontré ces gens
extraordinaires qui parlent parfaitement
l'hébreux l'arabe et l'anglais et qui
font des études qui ont fait des études
supérieures et dont le seul avenir il
faut bien dire est de partir et d'aller
travailler dans les monarchies du golf
où ils ont plus ou moins pris la la
succession des des Libanais hein pour
faire il font fonctionner les monarchies
du golf donc oui il faut essayer de
voir le problème de Gaza évidemment
c'est que c'est le Hamas qui lui a
étouffé absolument toute protestation
c'est et donc c'est assez c'est assez
différent le combat pour l'eau est un
combat essentiel parce que que si vous
regardez la géographie de la région vous
voyez que la s-jordanie est une sorte de
château d'eau qui approvisionne
au-dessus de la plaine côtière qui elle
est l'état d'Israël et
donc les les Israéliens il faut bien
dire ont pris le contrôle des ressources
en eau je ne me rappelle pas les
proportions de l'utilisation de l'eau
mais la majorité de l'eau de Sis
Jordanie est utilisé soit par l'État
d'Israël soit par les soit par les
implantations euh vous savez il y a
toute une euh il faudrait parler
vraiment de cette de cette colonisation
parce que par exemple l'Union européenne
finance des projets de développement des
projets de développement par exemple des
puits ou même des pro des projets de
développement de construction et souvent
ils sont détruits par les bulldoers
Israéliens euh parce que Israël
n'accorde aucun permis de construire par
définition donc ce qui veut dire que les
Palestiniens bah évidemment lap
population croit mais on ne leur accorde
pas des permis de des permis de
construire d'une certaine manière tout
est fait il faut bien dire pour que ils
comprennent que leur seule solution
c'est de partir voilà donc il y a et et
moi depuis maintenant quasiment 40 ans
je dis que nous devrions être beaucoup
plus énergiques sur ce sujet sur le
sujet de la colonisation c'est une
violation flagrante de la 4e Convention
de Genève et de sur ci et là je ne fais
pas de la morale parce que d'abord je je
suis un dipl un diplomate à moral don je
dis plus clairement je dis pas de
pléonasme oui pas de pléonasme je vous
remercie monsieur le Président hélas non
c'est pas un pléonas par certains de mes
collègues prétendent être au
Morau plus sérieusement c'est ce que la
colonisation prétend faire ou veut faire
c'est rendre impossible le compromis
territorial en mitemps vous savez au
sens de en mitant le la sisjordanie
d'une certaine manière ça rend aucun
gouvernement israélien on ne sera
capable d'envoyer l'armée pour pour
chasser 10 30 40 50000 60000 colons donc
il y a là un problème politique la
colonisation c'est aussi c'est
évidemment la dépossession des
Palestiniens mais c'est aussi un
problème politique contre la la solution
des deux états c'est très intéressant
très clair très intéressant monsieur
pour les socialistes Monsieur Alain
David qui est député de la Géronde merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur merci tout d'abord pour
votre éclairage sur la situation au
Proche Orient que vous connaissez très
bien pour y avoir exercé à plusieurs
reprises au cours de votre carrière de
diplomate également depuis que vous êtes
retiré la gravité des événements en
cours en Israël et dans les Territoires
palestiniens nous conduit à multiplier
les auditions et nous avons ainsi pu
percevoir et apprécier au plus près le
glissement de la parole présidentielle
vers cette demande salutaire de cesser
le
feu la voix de la France est nécessaire
mais malheureusement risque d'être
insuffisante pour espérer un apaisement
à court terme je vais donc prendre un
peu de recul par rapport à l'urgence de
la situation et aux questions
sécuritaires humanitaires et
diplomatiques pour vous interroger sur
les conséquences à long terme sur la
politique intérieure
d'Israël à votre avis est-ce que
l'attaque du SAT ob va renforcer
l'approche excluante du Premier ministre
netanahou
ou est-ce que ce coup de tonnerner va au
contraire inciter les Israéliens à
reconsidérer plus sérieusement la piste
des deux états comme perspective à une
coexistence pacifique même lointaine
avec un nouveau
gouvernement je
pense coupe ton ton voilà merci monsieur
le député je pense que que à très court
terme que comment réagiraient les
français si on avait massacré torturé à
mort 10000 français voyez ensuite ça ne
porte pas tellements Leuil voilà après
le deuil mais le deuil je ne sais pas
combien de temps il durera mais j'ai de
nouveau comme je le disais j'ai déjeuné
hier avec des amis israéliens et c'est
l'impression c'est le deuil c'est la
colère c'est la peur c'est le le
l'affolement vous savez il venaient ses
amis israéliens qu'est-ce qu'ils
venaient faire il venaient
installer leurs enfants chez les
grands-parents parce que à l'heure
actuelle on parle de Gaza évidemment
mais tous les jours il y a des alertes
des alertes sur Tel Aviv des roquettes
lancées voilà donc on est dans cet état
d'esprit et je ne vois pas vraiment
demain les les Palestiniens les
Israéliens direent on va on va négocier
on va faire des concessions donc je
dirais à court terme deuxème court terme
également c'est sans doute le départ de
Monsieur netaniaou les tous les sondages
prouve que le le Premier ministre est
vraiment considéré comme responsable
donc il y aura sans doute une évolution
politique euh est-ce que ce sera au sein
de la même majorité qui je le répète est
une majorité qui va jusqu'à l'ultra
drroite ou est-ce que ce sera un
gouvernement plus centriste euh voyez ça
fait partie des questions des questions
mais n'oublions pas que c'est un pays où
la gauche a disparu quand même donc même
ceux qui qui qui prendrai la place
succéderit à netanahou sont quand même
ne sont pas particulièrement des colombe
donc là aussi là aussi il y a beaucoup
de beaucoup de questions et d'une
certaine manière la diplomatie ça
devrait être de préparer cette cet après
le deuil voyez de d'un moment ou un
autre dans quelques mois ou de dire
voilà vous avez vu ce qui est arrivé ce
statut quo qui n'en est pas un en effet
j'aurais dû le répondre à Monsieur petit
ce statut quo qui en réalité n'en est
pas un parce que en Cisjordanie ça
permet au colons de continuer à
grignoter le la région de grignoter le
le territoire ire don vous voyez bien
que ce statut quo il paraissait
confortable il ne l'est pas du tout
c'est c'est l'espoir mais ça veut dire
aussi que il faut le dire le dire de
l'extérieur je ne suis pas sûr que ça
qu'il faille pas essayer de de susciter
un mouvement comme je l'ai dit en allant
en travaillant avec les Arabes en
travaillant avec les Européens et en
travaillant avec les Américains oui je
vous remercie je veux dire
j'ajoute pour répondre à Monsieur David
que ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
aller plus loin c'est-à-dire là vous
dites que le 7 octobre n'a évidemment
pas arrangé les choses mais ce que vous
avez montré dans votre propos liminaire
c'est que structurellement cette
solution des deux états n'a jamais été
du tout une solution acceptée pour les
raisons très très claires très fortes
que vous avez exprimé donc ça rend
l'affaire beaucoup plus difficile et ça
explique l'inquiétude et scepticisme de
certains d'entre nous par rapport à la
solution que évidemment nous appelons de
nos
vux monsieur tacher pour le le le groupe
écologique
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues Monsieur l'Ambassadeur d'abord
je veux m'associer au remerciement de de
mes collègues pour le plaisir de vous
avoir ce matin je crois que c'est
l'occasion de d'avoir une réflexion un
petit peu approfondie sur la trajectoire
de la politique française au proche-
Orient d'abord un mot général pour dire
que la diminution progressive des fonds
alloué à notre arsenal diplomatique
interroge sur notre capacité à encore
influencer sur le cours des événements
internationaux elle elle a certes été
légèrement inversé ces dernières années
mais beaucoup trop
faiblement et je crois qu'il est aussi
vraiment urgent pour la France de
renouver avec sa tradition humaniste sur
la question d'Israël et de la Palestine
vous avez toujours défendu une solution
à à deux états votre opposition n'a
d'ailleurs pas faibli mais l'évolution
récente de la politique française depuis
les attentats du 7 octobre souligné par
la note collective des ambassadeurs
qu'évoquait mon mon collègue logal
semble avoir suscité le malaise de
dizaines de diplomates si on en croit
même le journal Le Monde et c'est aussi
le cas de nombreux parlementaires dont
je fais partie le président Macron a en
effet d'abord promu un soutien
inconditionnel à Israël et a proposé
selon un raisonnement qui défie toute
logique une coalition internationale que
la coalition internationale qui lutte
contre daesh soit étendue au Hamas il a
ensuite appelé à une trêve qui
rappelonsle n'est pas un cessé le feu
avant de finalement s'y résoudre il y a
4 jours pour appeler le lendemain
Benjamin netanahou pour s'en excuser
cette position à mon sens elle traduit
un manque de vision à tout le moins et
les fluctuations et les revirements de
position nuisent à notre à notre
crédibilité la France qui était
autrefois un pilier de la diplomatie
mondiale semble désormais naviguer sur
Bousso donc j'aurai plusieurs questions
d'abord Sébastien Lecornu le ministre
des Armées entame une tournée au
Moyen-Orient très bien mais est-ce que
finalement cette décision prise par le
président Macron ne symbolise pas un
recul de la diplomatie au profit au
profit d'une approche un peu plus
militarisée ensuite sur l'engagement
historique de la France pour une
solution à deux états ma conviction
personnelle Monsieur l'Ambassadeur est
qu'elle est en réalité incompatible avec
la politique de soutien à ce que vous
avez vous-même appelé un un nettoyage
ethnique au détail actuellement mené en
Palestine et que la presse israélienne
elle-même décrit comme n'étant pas
destinée à mettre fin au terrorisme ou à
libérer les otages mais bel et bien a
enterré toute forme de création d'un
État palestinien donc que pouvons-nous
faire pour contrer cela est-ce que par
exemple il ne serait pas temps pour la
France de de reconnaître l'État de
Palestine comme l'Assemblée nationale et
le Sénat l' invite depuis 2014 et 2016
enfin dernière question vous avez
indiqué que il faudrait de nouveaux
interlocuteur pour que le processus de
paix est une chance d'aboutir je suis
d'accord avec vous évidemment mais en
Palestine il n'y a pas eu d'élection
depuis 15 ans et pourquoi la raison
avancée par par les Palestiniens est que
Jérusalem Est ne peut pas faire l'objet
d'un scrutin parce qu'il y a un blocage
d'Israël est-ce que sur ce point vous
vous partagez cette analyse et que la
France peut-elle faire pour débloquer
cette
situation merci
voilà un feu roulant de question inéress
Monsieur Merci monsieur le le député euh
non en ce qui concerne le ministre de la
Défense au ministre des Armées
aujourd'hui madame Colona s'est rendue
sur place elle a fait aussi elle est
allée à plusieurs main non deux reprises
au moins le président de la République
est allé donc le ministre de des armées
y ne me semble pas ne me semble pas pas
totalement ne me semble pas inutile s'il
n'y a pas eu d'élection depuis 2006
c'est pas lié du tout à à Jérusalem Est
c'est que les élections de 2006 avaient
entraîné la victoire du Hamas partout et
que alors là c'est un peu de l'histoire
parce
que vous savez donc j'étais
l'ambassadeur et on apprend la victoire
du Hamas partout hein aussi bien en C
Jordani qu'en quen c'est 2006 et et donc
je me évidemment je me dis zut quelles
vont être les conséquences là-dessus et
avant même que avant même que je prenne
ma que je je c'était un dimanche avant
même que je j'appelle Paris les
Israéliens m'appellent en me disant
formidable jacques shirac a dit on ne
parle pas au Hamas la France ne parlera
pas au Hamas sauf si le Hamas reconnaît
Israël reconnaît les accords d'Oslo et
renonce à la violence euh et d'une
certaine manière c'était alors moi ça
m'arrangé comme ambassadeur en Israël
mais bon voilà c'était d'une certaine
manière fermer le banc voilà euh fermer
le banc alors peut-être que je choquerai
certains d'entre vous mais je ne suis
pas sûr qu'en 2006 on nit pas eu intérêt
à parler au Hamas voilà mais ça c'est
une question question que personne
auquel on peut pas répondre
naturellement donc c'est là le problème
c'est que depuis 2006 la France a tout à
fait suivi vos vos interlocuteurs
israéliens ah bah oui coné ah totalement
elle s'est et même mais ça s'est fait
dans je dirais l'heure 1 heure après le
résultat des élections et c'était
Jacques Chirac c'était pas Nicolas
Sarkozi donc 1 heure après le résultat
des élections j'avais même pas eu le
temps d'appeler Paris et eu et donc et
s'il n'y a pas eu d'élection c'est tout
simplement parce que l'Autorité
palestinienne et les Israéliens n'en
veulent pas parce que pour de peur de la
victoire du Hamas depuis 2006 on en est
là hein c'est c'est le le côté c'est le
refus et c'est pour ça vous avez une
autorité palestienne complètement
discréditée dont on peut se demander s'
y n'est pas une annexe de service
israélien entre nous aujourd'hui et de
l'autre côté vous avez eu cette escalade
parce que cette au fond ce qui est
arrivé le 7 octobre ça quand même c'est
c'est une séquence c'est pas un acte
isolé en 201 nous avons eu aussi des
affrontements déjà en 2011 en 2008 en
2011 en 2014 en 2021 autour de Gaza où
le le le le le Hamas lançait des lançit
des volets de de roquet à l'aveugle sur
le territoire sur le territoire
israélien au fond ce qui sépare cette
cette attaque des précédente c'est que
elle a réussi elle a réussi d'abord son
ampleur sans doute et aussi son succès
totalement son son succès donc on était
voyez une sorte de au fond haramala
l'Autorité palestinienne disait bon ben
voilà le le le Hamas et Gaza et disons
bien les les Palestiniens du Hamas et
les Palestiniens de l'Autorité
palestinienne s'entretu c'est pas une
rivalité une rivalité politique encore
que peut-être entre les partis
politiques français ça pourrait mais
entre le Hamas et la vous avez pas
encore atteint ce stade et donc c'est
donc il s'entretu et moi je peux vous
dire j'en ai eu la PR preuve certaines
cibles de Gaza étai donné par l'Autorité
palestinienne aux Israéliens en disant
voilà ils sont là le Hamas taper de
taper dessus donc vous voyez l'ambiance
dans laquelle dans laquelle dans
laquelle on est autre question monsieur
le
député votre sur la reconnaissance de
l'État Palestine alors là moi je
j'appartiens à une catégorie assez rare
au k d'oré j'aime bien qu'une que ça
serve à quelque chose et et franchement
la
reconnaissance je vois pas se servirait
voilà c'est tout vous voyez c'est c'est
de nouveau mais on peut le faire on peut
le concevoir c'est un acte politique on
peut concevoir un acte symbolique
politique et ça mais là je dirais ça
c'est aux autorités politiques de le
faire hein si ça s'intègre aussi
peut-être dans une démarche plus plus
vaste pourquoi pas mais honnêtement d'un
point de vue professionnel je dirais ça
sert pas à grand-chose voilà c'est euh
c'est mais nous avons soutenu par
exemple au nationsunis le fait
que que le l'OLP devenait observateur et
état observateur au sein des Nations
Unies ça nous l'avions c'est même moi
qui l' qui qui est levé la main pour la
qui est levé la main pour la
France bien c'est c'est très clair cette
ce souci de de fonctionnalité et
d'efficacité tout à votre honneur
monsieur le coq pour la Gauche démocrate
et
républicaine
pardon moi le temps que c'est pas rouge
je n'interviens pas merci Monsieur
l'ambassade
merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur pour pour
vos
propos d'abord parce qu'il nous il nous
rappelle qu'il y avait une histoire
avant le 7 octobre avant le drame du 7
octobre et et ces dernières semaines on
avait l'impression que toute l'histoire
commençait le 7 octobre alors vous nous
avez bien montré que depuis le 7 octobre
c'est une autre histoire qui commence
certes et et j'apprécie beaucoup
l'éclairage que que vous nous donnez ce
matin sur sur ce sujet-là sur la
question du statut qu moi je fais partie
de ceux qui peuvent pas considérer qu'il
y avait un statut quo parce que je fais
partie de ceux et y en a ici qui qui
pendant des décennies ont alerté qui
pendant qu'il y avait ni guerre ni paix
ont alerté sur le fait de faire évoluer
la situation il y a beaucoup de
dirigeants politiques français des
dirigeants importants qui qui parlent de
Gaza comme d'une prise on à ciel ouvert
qui parlait de gazade comme d'une prison
à ciel ouvert comment on peut considérer
que des gens peuvent vivre éternellement
dans une prison à ciel ouvert qu'il y
aurait un statut co que ça marcherait
comme ça c'est pas possible et tout le
monde ou alors s'il y avait une une
naïveté internationale israélienne
peut-être pour considérer que ça pouvait
tenir et je peux pas croire qu'il y
avait une naïveté et donc on a essayé
jusqu'au bout jusqu'à l'année dernière
jusqu'à jusqu'au fait de dénoncer la
politique israélienne qui qui comme le
disait l'ONU se pouvait s'apparenter à
de la parteé pouvait tout ça mis bout à
bout et sans réaction internationale
forte à chaque fois ne pouvait que
conduire à des drames selon moi et et et
peut-être selon vous aussi et donc il
est il est
important et c'est et c'est étonnant
pour Israël qui était attentif à sa
sécurité et tout de de ne pas mesurer
parce que je veux bien qu'il soit pas
paranoïque mais si en plus ils sont
naïfs c'est une c'est c'est c'est enfin
vraiment être dirigé par des gens comme
ça ça ça ça m'inquiète et puis on a une
petite discussion hier dans cette
commission et ça donnera la la
continuité où o je questionnais sur y
a-t-il un avenir pour un État
palestinien la solution à deux états
est-elle crédible et et pour qu'il a
solution à deux états faut qu'il y ait
reconnaissance de l'État palestinien
pour qu'il ait discussion et mise autour
de la table il faut qu'il y ait un état
qui parle à un
état je pense que ça commence aussi par
ça et on avait la possibilité de le
faire depuis des décennies l'Assemblée
nationale nous y avait invité et ouais
je sais mais j'ai rien dit ouais ben ça
suffit ouais mais je je sais bien vous
n'avez rien dit mais vous avez fait le
geste je suis très sensible à vos gestes
monsieur le Président ça le geste qu'a
fait le président c'était pour m'inviter
à m'arrêter mais mais comme on est
obligé de peser nos mots comme on est
obligé de prendre beaucoup de
précautions pour parler de cette
situation parce qu'on voit bien le
contexte dans lequel on est le climat
dans lequel on est le temps qui nous est
imparti pour le faire est toujours très
compliqué sauf à bien poser ses mots à
les écrire et aller lire moi j'essaie de
ne pas vous de ne pas le faire le le
plus possible parce que je pense que ça
ça me permet de m'adapter à ce que vous
avez dit justement et à ce qui s'est dit
par mes collègues donc ça ça nécessite
parfois quelques secondes de plus merci
je vous merci monsieur le député je suis
tenté en vous écoutant de rappeler que
pour un certain nombre de gens don moi
je crois que la naïveté est la forme la
plus élaborée du cynisme je Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur c'est
euh non de de nouveau il y a vous avez
je suis toujours je suis toujours
analytique hein face à un problème il
faut essayer de voir quelles sont les
solutions concevables les solutions
concevables c'est la solution à deux
états la solution à un état pas de
solution parce que honnêtement vous
savez je vais être je vais être cynique
à défaut d'être naïf mais le nombre de
fois où on m'a on m'a dit ah ça ne sera
plus comme avant et puis ça a été comme
avant c'està dire voyez voilà donc on ne
peut pas non plus exclure que l'on ne
revienne pas d'une manière ou d'une
autre après 10000 morts qu'on ne
revienne pas à une situation qui soit
plus ou moins la même chose parce que on
ne VO parce que on ne voit pas de de
manière de de de progresser moi je je je
sais bien que là ce que je dis peut
choquer tout le monde ou ou dire mais
non c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible mais j'ai connu tellement de
crises où on m'a dit rien ne sera comme
avant alors que tout a été comme avant
que je dirais bon voilà nous pouvons
nous ne pouvons pas ure le retour le
retour en effet à un statu qu qui
n'était pas un statu qu comme je l'ai
dit et comme Monsieur petit l'avait dit
également la solution à un état je
dirais que dans le personnellement dans
le meilleur des mondes ce serait sans
doute la meilleure mais elle est hors
elle est totalement hors de question
parce que ce serait évidemment la fin
d'Israël la fin de l'État d'Israël comme
l'état juif et c'est quand même la
raison d'être d'Israël c'est quand même
d'être d'être l'État juif et puis ce
serait de mettre deux populations qui se
qui se haïssent qui se haïsent qui de
toute façon répondent aussi à des
logiques internes totalement différentes
euh un moi je un vous connaissez sans
doute d'ailleurs un ancien ambassadeur
d'Israël à Paris qui est un intellectuel
Eddie
Barnavi voilà voà juste après et voilà
et
Ie d'ailleurs parle du gouvernement
actuel comme étant des imbéciles
incompétents israélien actuel mais Ie
moi je me rappelle en Israël il m'avait
dit un jour non la seule solution c'est
un divorce sans affect un divorce sans
affect c'est vraiment on est vous êtes
là nous sommes là et voilà c'est c'est
de états les deux états c'est beaucoup
plus commode que l'absence parce que ça
cré ça crée une barrière ça crée et or
il y a or il y a eu déjà une barrière
barrière de sécurité donc voilà donc il
ne reste pas l'état unique est
impossible le le le retour à la à la à
la le retour et moi à mon avis il me
semble être contrairement à ce que
beaucoup disent le plus probable
la négociation de des États en effet
c'est ça sans doute la bonne solution
mais vous savez sils ont échoué parce
que les les Américains ont quand même
essayé pendant 30 ans hein deu enfin 20
ans de conduire la négociation depuis
les accords deos slow et ça a échoué et
honnêtement alors je le dis dans le
livre que je suis en train d'écrire ça
ne sert à rien de chercher des
responsabilités des deux côtés ils sont
sont responsables du côté israélien
parce que je suis convaincu qu'au fond
de même il ne voulait pas céder la S
Jordanie et du côté palestin parce que
ils ont été incapables pour multiples
raisons de prendre le contrôle de de de
de de prendre le contrôle des groupes
terroristes car n'oublions pas que un
certain nombre de d'étapes où le
processus de paix a déraillé c'est parce
qu'il y a eu des campagnes terroristes
lancées par notamment lancé par le Hamas
en 96 ce qui a mené netanahou pour
Premier ministre d'ailleurs ce qui a
permis ensuite à netanahou de faire
dérailler le processus de le processus
d'Oslo donc il y a une alliance
évidemment entre entre les les les
extrémistes donc de nouveau une chance
sur sang que ça marche mais nous devons
travailler sur cette solution et euh et
il faut travailler dans le dans le temps
il faut travailler dans le temps long
euh en prenant je dirais tous les
éléments et en essayant de les traiter
de manière globale je vous remercie le
dernier orateur au titre des groupes euh
c'est au titre des nonincrits c'est
Monsieur du
ponteignan voilà ça marche merci
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur je ne reviendrai pas sur
l'engrenage des tragédies l'attaque
terroriste abominable du Hamas la
terrible situation humanitaire à Gaza je
ne reviendrai pas sur la politique de
notre pays étrangère qui donne le tourni
je crois qu'il est quand même important
de rappeler que seul le droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux-même devrai
inspirer notre politique même si on vous
l'avez expliqué c'est extrêmement
difficile le droit d'existence d'Israël
défendre aussi mais aussi le droit du
peuple palestinien à enfin avoir son
état François mitteran dont je ne suis
pas suspect d'être un admirateur avait
une phrase extraordinaire qui disait
deux peuples pour une même terre avec un
Dieu de chaque côté et on voit bien que
la tragédie du 7 octobre
a détruit l'idée détruit l'idée que l'on
pouvait contourner la question
palestinienne contourner l'occupation
des TER territoires occupés
et je crois que ce n'est pas être
hostile à Israël c'est peut-être même
lui rendre service que de considérer que
seule la solution à à deux états peut
assurer à terme la sécurité d'Israël et
que la folie actuelle qui s'est emparée
de cette région montre bien qu'après
avoir refusé la situation des deux états
on a une situation pire moi j'ai trois
questions très précises à vousoser le
Hamas où sont les dirigeants est-ce
qu'ils sont à Gaza ou est-ce qu'ils sont
ailleurs qui les a financé comment ils
ont été financés quelle est la part du
gouvernement israélien dans cette
affaire ou d'autres États deuxème
question jusqu'où peut aller
l'indifférence des régimes arabes qui
avaient accepté l'accord d'Abraham
vis-à-vis de la souffrance des
Palestiniens fragilité de l'Égypte sur
le plan économique possibilité de
révolution de palais en Arabie Saoudite
quel est votre avis là-dessus même si
vous en avez abondamment parler enfin
3ème point jusqu'à où jusqu'où iront les
Israéliens dans la colonisation la S
Jordanie qui vous l'avez très bien
expliqué est faite pour empêcher toute
solution d'avenir et qui est une folie
pour la sécurité même
d'Israël je crois que ce sont trois
questions importantes qui ont d'ailleurs
déjà été assez largement traitées par
notre invité mais je crois que préciser
les
choses alors euh non non c'est c'est
donc en ce qui concerne donc la la la en
ce qui concerne donc la colonisation en
six jouranie hein comme je vous l'ai dit
c'est une c'est une violation du droit
international la 4e Convention de Genève
qui interdit à la puissance d'occupation
de modifier l'équilibre démographique
d'une d'une région d'une région occupée
euh je l'ai dit aussi il y a à peu près
500000 colons mais la grande majorité
sont dans des blocs de colonisation
autour de Jérusalem et donc pourrait
être introduit euh euh reportter vers
Israël moyenant des des des euh des
rectifications de frontières
relativement minimes en revanche il y a
un certain nombre de de de
d'implantations à l'intérieur de la
sisjordanie avec souvent des colons qui
sont armés voire voire fanatisés donc là
la question se pose est-ce que un état
israélien quel qu'il soit un
gouvernement israélien serait capable de
rapatrier de rapatrier certains disent
et je trouve c'est de la mauvaise foi en
disant ah bon vous voulez qu'un État
palestinien soit Juden rein soit sans
Juifs enfin soyons sérieux on sait très
bien que les colons israéliens n'accept
aurit jamais la loi d'un d'un État
palestinien et donc il est évident que
si on veut créer un état viable et
contigu il faudrait rapatrier un certain
nombre de colons de colons israéliens et
moi je trouve que c'est c'est
extrêmement compliqué aujourd'hui et de
nouveau je doute que ce ne soit que ce
ne soit possible dans les conditions
politiques dans les conditions
politiques les conditions politiques
actuelles euh en ce qui concerne les
pays arabes
euh vous savez ces pays quand même
contrôlent assez bien leur population
hein et euh euh et donc pour le moment
les monarchies du golf et l'Égypte sont
évidemment ne sont pas à l'aise c'est le
moins que l'on puisse dire parce que
leur population est massivement
favorable au Hamas mais jusqu'à
maintenant elles ont réussi à tenir en
canalisant la par en faisant des
réunions en faisant en faisant des
déclarations et il y a aussi une petite
musique qu'il ne faut pas négliger une
petite musique qui croit qui est contre
le Hamas qui prend la pop poultion arabe
la population de Gaza en otage on a de
plus en plus des petits films qui
montrent des des gens qui ont perdu leur
leur père leur mère leur enfant et qui
disent qui hurlent à la télévision c'est
la faute du Hamas voyez donc il y a
aussi et il y a des journalistes des
journalistes dans le monde arabe qui
critiquent le Hamas en disant c'est le
Hamas qui est responsable donc pour le
moment ENF évidemment je ne peux pas
prévoir de de les révolutions de palais
il y a un seul pays qui a renvoyé qui a
rappelé son son ambassadeur et c'est
très révélateur parce que c'est la
l'état le plus fragile de la région
c'est le Bahrain vous savez le Bahrain
c'est une minorité sunnite qui dirige
une majorité chiite un régime évidemment
autoritaire et là ils ont voilà ils sont
c'est eux qui ont dans la dans la la
région qui ont fait leur et en effet
quand il y a aussi le problème la
question la question de la Turquie qui
se pose mais là elle se pose dans le
cadre des ambitions régionale de
régionale ottomane de de de la Turquie
AR le le les les Turcs ont été plus plus
plus du côté de des puissances les plus
agressives ah totalement la Turquie a a
pris une ligne qui est extrêmement
agressive extrêmement euh
anti-israélienne mais ce n'est pas
nouveau hein il y avait déjà eu une
rupture entre Israël et la Turquie
récemment et anti-américaine mais euh
c'est assez étonnant parce que euh je
sais pas vous connaissez peut-être
l'ambassadeur de Turquie ici est est
excellent hein il est d'ailleurs de la
de la promotion de l'enat du président
de la République euh et euh et donc il
est le la Turquie très francophone il
est la Turquie francophone et
extrêmement policée mais quand vous
regardez les déclarations des ministres
de herdohan ils sont ahurissantes ce
sont des déclarations violemment
anti-occidentales on voit bien que la
Turquie fait partie de ces pays qui ont
recouvré leur puissance c'est la fin du
moment occidental voilà la Turquie a
toujours été un grand pays il le
redevient bien il le redevient avec les
ambitions les ambitions d'un les
ambitions d'un grand pays euh
excusez-moi monsieur le député la
première question Hamas le le le Hamas
le Hamas ah oui bah le Hamas on le sait
très clairement ça a été le le soutien
vous savez le soutien au mouvement
islamiste à l'origine ce sont les les
services israéliens hein qui ont
considéré que c'était une manière
d'affaiblir l'OLP donc il a eu un jeu
des services israéliens et ensuite au
Gaza le jeu de évidemment du
gouvernement netanah c'était divisé pour
régner donc d'un côté le Hamas gouverne
Gaza de l'autre l' aorité palestinienne
et j'aurais tendance à dire bah voilà
c'était tout bnef pour pour le
gouvernement netaniaahou qui du coup
laissait laisser l'argent flot couler
depuis le Qatar c'est le Qatar qui
l'argent coulait alors ce que les
Israéliens ne savaiit pas ù Savit ou ne
pouvait rien faire c'est que les armes
elles coulaient par la frontière
égyptienne parce qu'on oublie quand même
que le le le le le Gaza ce n'est pas un
blocus israélien c'est un blocus
israélo-égyptien et et comme vous vous
le savez je dirais que le douanier
égyptien n'est pas totalement
imperméable au au moyen de de voilà
moyen financier il n'est pas le seul
sans doute mais en particulier étant
donné les salaires de de des Égyptiens
et donc le les armes le flot des armes
et peut-être de l'argent iranien passé
par le côté par le côté égyptien pendant
que l'argent du Hamas avec l' avec le le
soutien du gouvernement israélien aller
aller au Hamas également
bien je je vous remercie nous avons peu
de temps nous avons encore nous avons
les les groupes se sont exprimés nous
avons encore cinq parlementaires qui ont
demandé la parole donc dans un un délai
plus plus bref d'une minute mais je vais
commencer je vais sans doute lui laisser
un peu plus de temps parce que il a
quand même un statut assez particulier
je crois d'ailleurs que vous avez rompu
quelques lances avec lui
euh le le député des Français de
l'étranger de l'État d'Israël qui va
parler en premier qui est Monsieur
meilleur Habib il est pas il est pas
député des Français de l'État d'Israël
comment il est pas député il est député
des Français de l'État d'Israël oui j'ai
l'honneur d'être avoir élu à quatre
reprises par les 180000 Français
d'Israël qui m'ont élu entre au deuxème
tour entre 80 et 90 % sur 4 élections ce
qui me donne une certaine légimité pour
parler en leur nom Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur monsieur le
Président en peu de temps que j'ai ma
conviction absolue nous devons changer
de logiciel cette guerre n'est pas une
guerre de territoire c'est une guerre de
civilisation Israël est sortie de la
bande de Gaza du Liban du Sinaï était
prêt à signer les accords d'Oslo hélas
la haine du Juif et je l'ai dit le
l'afhrodisiac du monde Arab pas des pas
de leurs leaders leur leaders on a voulu
d'ailleurs casser les accords d'Abraham
je ne sais pas s'ils y arriveront ou pas
mais hélas je le vois dans ses
manifestations à Paris dans ton crie en
permanence du Jourdain à la Méditerranée
par ailleurs donc c'est ma conviction
absolue si en ne changeant pas
aujourd'hui cette cette ce logiciel nous
n'arriverons à rien Israël est sorti
jusqu'au dernier centimètre carré de la
bande de Gaza Charon que j'ai bien connu
a décidé de tout faire pour arriver à
une paix qu' n'a pas réussi à faire un
mot je vous le dis je le redis fortement
un juif ne sera jamais un colon en judé
un français peut être colon en Algérie
au Togo
euh un britannique en rodésie mais un
juif ne sera jamais un colon en Judée il
on pe avoir des territoires contestés
vous êtes un fin connaisseur revenir aux
accords sapico de savoir ce qui était la
Palestine avant 1923 avant la
déclaration baltour le cadeau de du
ministre des Colonies cherschill à
l'mirabdalla on n' pas le temps pour en
parler de savoir ce que c'est que la
Jordanie donc on peut contester les
territoires un juif ne sera jamais un
colon en Judée évidemment et Jérusalem
la capitale du peuple juif alors que
notre capitale Lutes était encore un
demiarécage était déjà la capitale du
peuple juif c'est la la réalité après
encore une fois question déjà 2 minutes
je vous dis juste un mot parce que le
l'ambassadeur merci monsieur le
Président je terminerai je j'ai beaucoup
de j'apprécie l'ambassadeur Gérard AR je
le connu je mais lorsqu'il parle de
nettoyage ethnique c'est indigne c'est
faux et c'est un mensonge il y a pas de
nettoyage ethnique en Israël et et de le
fait de quelqu'un de sa qualité qui
emploie de tel termes met de l'huile sur
le feu feu c'est faux c'est indigne et
c'est un mensonge je vous
remercie je n'ai pas parlé de
de en si sordanie il y a un étoage
ethnique au détail qui est en train
d'être fait 175 Palestiniens ont été
tués en 2 mois des villages sont vidés
les colons font des descentes armées
avec la connivance de l'armée dans les
villages oui il y a un nettoyage
ethnique au détail je crois que c'est
toutes les informations qu'on a vont
dans le sens de ce que vient de dire
monsieur
je répondre non non mais ben non vous
avez posé la question on vous a répondu
maends la la la la discussion en
revanche continuera mais au-delà de de
ça madame madame
Tangui alors vous une minute
he c'est pas parce que je suis
finistérienne que j'ai pas un avis
finistè une minute merci monsieur le
Président bon la France a condamné avec
la plus grande fermeté des attaques
terroristes mené par le Hamas contre
Israël et sa population et donc la
situation humanitaire étant extrêmement
grave le président Macron a eu
l'initiative d'une conférence
humanitaire qui permet quand même
d'arriver à un consensus pour une trêve
humanitaire et une une aide
internationale pour faire face aux
besoins des populations civiles et je
voudrais dire ici que face à la à
l'ampleur de cette catastrophe
humanitaire la France a également dit
ouvertement à Israël d'épargner les
civils et d'arrêter les la poursuite des
frappes indiscriminées sur Gaza car les
populations civiles n'ont pas payer le
prix des crimes du Hamas et de la
riposte israélienne alors malgré votre
vision pessimiste pour l'avenir
pensez-vous Monsieur l'Ambassadeur que
la position française qui a été
réaffirmée par le Président de la
République et la ministre des Affaires
étrangères d'obtenir une trêve
humanitaire pouvant mener à un cesselfeu
peut constituer malgré tout un premier
pas pour relancer le processus de paix
restaurer un horizon politique à deux
États qui est la seule solution viable
permettant à chaque parti de vivre en
paix et en sécurité et éviter le risque
d'embrasement de la région
merci donc l'hypothèse de la trêve
humanitaire est une hypothèse où
beaucoup d'ailleurs de d'acteurs
internationaux s'activent et notamment
les États-Unis le président de la
République la France et les États-Unis
je voudrais simplement faire la remarque
que pour le cesser le feu le cesser le
feu aujourd'hui aux yeux d'israëlle
représenterait la victoire du Hamas et
donc c'est cela le fait qui fait que
c'est très difficile d'espérer que c'est
c'est le feu ça voudrait dire que le
Hamas contrôle la bande de garde le
contrôle de la bande de Gaza et peut
négocier la libération la libération des
otage ce serait donc la consécration
d'une victoire stratégique du Hamas au
dépend d'Israël et c'est pour ça je
pense que Israël n'acceptera n'acceptera
jamais mais ça n'empêche pas en effet de
travailler sur une trêve une trêve
humanitaire sur des corridors
humanitaires et il faut faire le il faut
c'est notre devoir aussi hein de tout
faire pour venir au secours d'une
population qui qui est prise en en qui
est prise au piège à la fois par le
Hamas et et maintenant par
l'intervention
israélienne très bien merci Monsieur
monsieur
Ji merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur alors l'évolution de la
situation en Israël et dans les
Territoires palestiniens dépend
évidemment très largement du
positionnement des États-Unis et du
degré de soutien que le gouvernement
apporte à Israël et donc dans ce cadre
l'approche d'une élection présidentielle
encore plus norme hors norme que la
précédente et puis l'éventuel retour du
président Trump qui est favoris dans les
sondages constitue l'une des principales
clés d'un règlement politique du conflit
alors je Souha de connaître Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur votre avis sur l'impact
d'un tel retour au pouvoir sur la
situation en Israël et plus largement
sur la politique américaine au
Moyen-Orient qui en sortirait
certainement grandement bouleversé je
vous remercie euh monsieur le député
vous avez tout à fait raison de de
penser à l'hypothèse de d'une victoire
de Donald Trump les sondages sont sont
ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui nous avons
encore un an hein mais en effet euh vous
savez on sait ce que ce que Donald Trump
peut fait la manière dont Donald Trump
considère le conflit il est très proche
personnellement de Benjamin netanahou et
euh sous son premier mandat son Beaufils
Jaret Kouchner avait conduit une
tentative de médiation avait proposé un
plan de paix mais c'était un plan de
paix qui franchement était tellement
caricaturalement pro-israélien que il
n'avait pas euh il n'avait il n'avait
rencontré aucun écho donc si en cas de
victoire de Donald Trump encore que
Donald Trump est est relativement
imprévisible on peut imaginer un soutien
de Donald Trump au gouvernement
israélien je dirais quel qu'il soit en
effet dernier point pour être pour
respecter le temps c'est que le soutien
à Israël qui était un soutien des deux
partis comme je l'ai dit est un soutien
maintenant qui devient de plus en plus
un soutien républicain le parti
républicain devient le soutien centrale
d'Israël aux États-Unis puisqueune
partie du des démocrates la gauche
démocrate est devenue u plus
particulièrement pro
palestinienne ce qui est plutôt
préoccupant pour l'avenir du Parti
démocrate
euh Monsieur
catnin Merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur les les massacres
du 7 octobre commis par le Hamas sur des
civil israélien ont soulevé notre
émotion et notre écurement après avoir
apporté son soutien inconditionnel à
l'État d'Israël malgré les risques
évidents de crime de guerre puis
plusieurs semaines de silence malgré la
multiplication des victimes civiles et
des bombardements aveugles du blocus et
du siège de Gaza le président de la
République a enfin ce jeudi 10 novembre
officiellement appelé à l'instauration
d'un cesser le feu cette position timide
avancée vers le simple respect du droit
international lui a valu des injures sur
plusieurs chaînes d'information en
continu à peine 48 heures après cette
déclaration le président de la
République français était même traité
d'antisémite sur une chaîne
d'information nous n'avons pas entendu
de soutien au président de la République
de la part de députés de sa majorité ni
de membres du gouvernement Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur que répondre face à
l'infamie d'une telle insulte quand on a
pour seul tort que de vouloir faire
respecter le droit international et
devraer à la paix que répondre à ceux
qui par ces méthodes abandonnent la
position diplomatique historique de la
France Monsieur le Député là vous me
vous me posez une question qui est
endelà de au-delà de mes de mes
compétences euh j'essae très très
clairement d'être un expert voyez
c'est-à-dire que j'essaie non pas
d'mettre des opinions j'essaie de dire à
partir de ce que je sais j'essaie de
vous définir le champ du possible voilà
qu'est-ce qui me semble possible et donc
lorsque je dis par exemple puisque c'est
une manière de rebondir sur ce que la
question du cesser le feu je ne dis pas
euh il est mauvais de de faire appel de
de faire un appel au cesser le feu je
dis moi ma connaissance ma compréhension
d'Israël fait que je pense que Israël
n'acceptera pas un cesser le feu voilà
c'est tout ce que moi voilà voilà un
petit peu comment je conçois ma présence
ma présence ici évidemment j'ai mes
opinions et peut-être elles peuvent
apparaître mais je peux vous assurer je
fais tout pour les combattre pour
essayer de de parce que très souvent il
y a le le Yaka faucon et cetera voilà
moi je dis voilà le alors en ce qui
concerne les accusations d'antisémitisme
alors là je peux vous assurer que j'ai
passé 6 ans de ma vie en Israël alors là
c'est un pays méditerranéen donc le le
le le le pire et l'inverse vol dès dès
que dès que vous dites quelque chose on
vous accuse d'être antisémite ou et
cetera donc ça fait partie un petit peu
je pense que que le Président de la
République doit avoir une peau quand
même un peu renforcée après 6 ans de
après 6 ans de mandat et ne doit pas
être particulièrement ému par ce genre
par ce genre de de de réaction non
Israël c'est le problème un petit peu
mais ça a toujours été le problème et on
peut l'expliquer de manière Israël ne
conçoit qu'une qu'une une attitude le
soutien inconditionnel n'est-ce pas dès
que vous manifestez la moindre réserve
aussitôt vous êtes accusé de de trahison
d'antisémitisme ou d'autres donc voilà
ça fait partie un petit peu euh je
dirais du du pays hein c'est c'est un
pays de passion c'est un pays de peur
euh ils ont la peur au ventre c'est
c'est ça qui est terrible et c'est ça
l'héritage de de de de la du génocide
hein ces gens c'est c'est la super vous
pouvez dire puissance nucléaire super
puissance de la région euh le pb
d'Israël 25 fois le pb des Palestiniens
c'est plus que le PIB de l'Égypte de la
Jordanie et de la Syrie réuni et bien
néanmoins ces gens ont la peur au vendre
et c'est comme ça et il faut répondre à
cela euh pour essayer euh d'aller
d'aller de
l'avant merci euh je je crois que tout
le monde s'est exprimé moi je voudrais
euh ajouter une une dernière question
euh ce qui m'a ce qui m'a frappé je je
vous ensr parce que moi-même j'ai
beaucoup mis l'accent dans les
différentes déclarations qu' qu'on a pu
faire sur le le problème de laassis
Jordanie vous en avez parlé vous avez
montré à quel point c'était une affaire
absolument centrale pour Israël et et
pour le rapport avec évidemment les
Palestiniens il reste Gaza vous avez
très peu parlé de Gaza et il reste que
moi la querelle du C le feu de trêve et
cetera c'est je trouve qu'elle est
seconde mais vous avez dit que vous ne
PZ pas intervenir en qualité d'expert
militaire bien vous vous en chchez
certainement beaucoup plus que beaucoup
de prétendus experts mais ce que je ne
comprend pas c'est la la la la la
stratégie de destruction si vous voulez
il y avait il y avait plusieurs
possibilités pour pour pour Israël pour
maintenir une pression très forte ils
auraient pu avoir une une approche
imitée de de Munich en disant il y a
nous avons le nom de 2000 personnes il y
en aura plus un de vivant dans dans 200
enfin bon ce genre enfin ils avaient
plusieurs ils ont choisi quelque chose
qui ne peut avoir de sens que euh qu'en
rendant totalement invivable d'abord en
tuant massivement des populations ne
serait-ce que on sait bien ce que c'est
que des bombardements aériens ce que
nous avons fait les Alliés en en
Allemagne et en Normandie d'ailleurs
pendant la seconde guerre mondial ça a
été quand même absolument
euh les résultats ont pas du tout été à
la hauteur de qui les des bombardement
on a eu énormément de de de de
destruction collatérale et cetera pour
on on ferait autrement maintenant eux
ils ont choisi cette voie et ils ont
choisi donc de
rendre invivable et en plus ils disent
qu'ils ne veulent pas l'occuper donc qui
va s'occuper on a l'impression qu' ils
détruisent tout et ils jettent la clé
euh qui qui va s' c'est c'est cette
grande incertitude et ça pose
indirectement le problème du Hamas vous
avez dit monsieur monieur l'ambassadeur
et je crois que c'est c'est évident que
tous les États arabes détestaient le
Hamas seulement quand on les voit quand
on discute avec chacun d'entre eux ils
nous disent tous vous ne pouvez pas
échapper à un dialogue direct ou
indirect avec le Hamas si vous voulez
reconstituer une Autorité palestinienne
respectable et et bon et et et et cette
impasse là elle est elle est absolument
terrifiante cette guerre est une guerre
qui est une pure violence c'est une
sorte de loi du talion que je comprends
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
sur la le le la légitimité de la défense
l'horreur de qui a été le 7 le 7 octobre
le le les traumatismes historiques du du
peuple juif enfin tout ça a jouer dans
dans le sens que vous dites mais en même
temps on ne voit pas du tout comment on
peut sortir de cet imbroliot à terme de
de la bande de Gaza de la présence du
Hamas et d'une solution qui tienne
debout bien vous vous vous rejo oigner
mon désespoir monsieur le
Président voilà car grand il est
grarement d'un grand optimisme mais je
le je le comprends tout à fait c'est
vrai que bon j'ai parlé quand même un
certain nombre de d'officiers généraux
du cadre de réserve mais aussi du cadre
d'active il ne voi pas ce que les
Israéliens peuvent atteindre il ne voi
pas quel pourrait être l'objectif
stratégique parce que l'objectif
tactique les objectifs tactiques il y en
a on va tuer des Hamas on va détruire
des et cetera et cetera voilà des
tunnels et tout le reste mais quel est
l'objectif stratégique c'est-à-dire
après à la fin de l'opération en quoi le
théâtre sera différent si ce n'est
qu'une grande partie de la de Gaza sera
détru une grande partie de Gaza sera
détruite mais voilà je je ne je n'ai pas
plus de réponse que cela je peux j'en ai
parlé à des officiers comme je vous
aussi vous avez dû en parler à des
officiers généraux qui disent non on
voit pas euh parce que vous savez vous
tuez les les dirigeants du Hamas groupe
terroriste mais ça veut dire que 3 mois
plus tard vous en avez des plus jeun et
des plus
radicau des plus jeunes et des plus
radicaux de surcroix vous détruisez des
armes bon ben voilà on corrompra on
corrompra les douaniers égyptiens et on
aura on aura encore des des armes donc
je suis tout à fait et et hier donc dans
mon dans ma rencontre avec mes amis
israéliens il me il me disait mais ceci
ce n'est qu'une opération de vengeance
il disait c'est une opération de
vengeance mais on ne voit c'est la loi
du
talion parce que si on on m'en a tué un
je dois en tuer 10 pour pouvoir rétablir
la ma capacité de dissuasion mais
au-delà ils ne voyent eux-même disaient
mais non on va pas on va pas administrer
la bande de Gaza on va pas chasser les 2
millions de gazaouille et vous pensez
bien que responsabilité en tant que
puissance occupante totalement parce que
contrairement à ce que disait ce que
disait un député un député des Français
et l'étranger les Israéliens ne sont pas
sortis de la bande de Gaza ils
contrôlent à la fois l'espace aérien et
l'espace naval et enroit intern
nationale la bande de Gaza est toujours
un territoire occupé c'est il faut le il
faut aussi le rappeler il av fermé ça au
hamaas c'était une idée comme une
affermage c'est exactement ça bien
écoutez c'était absolument passionnant
je crois que l'optimisme n'était pas au
rendez-vous mais la rigueur l'analyse la
lucidité je pense que nous devons
vraiment un grand TMO un grand signe de
de reconnaissance manifestation c'est
c'est formidable de d'être venu ici
d'avoir parler sans langue de bois euh
sans sans sans sans sans faux semblant
sans faux sentiment sans naïveté donc
sans cynisme si on en on en J c'était
vraiment cher ami c'était vraiment tout
à fait tout à fait précieux je crois que
la Commission évidemment ils sont pas
toujours là parce que ils passent leur
vie aérée entre les entre les différents
bâtiments de ce palais Bourbon mais ceci
est enregistré ils vont tous regarder ça
ça nous a énormément é
vraiment grand merci d'être venu ici et
d'avoir parlé dans les termes que vous
avez choisi de nous délivrer cé un
honneur d'avoir é voilà la séance est
levée